[Music]
foreign
it's getting hot it's summer time folks
welcome everybody
oh yeah quick thank you to hellofresh
and boy that's a nice looking Burger
that's actually a beautiful photo one of
our football Troopers took that that's
right what the f with the fries all like
out of focus like damn son
look at that that looks incredible
hellofresh delivers fresh quality
produce from the farm to your door in
less than a week so you can Savor
flavors all season long get 16 free
meals plus three gifts with coupon code
h3tv 16 at hellofresh.com
h3tv16 thank you hellofresh
God bless you
and welcome everybody happy Monday
Wednesday shots are it's not it's
literally Monday dude like you this
dude's got to get his head on straight
let's get neurodivergent we did a remix
because
you know the song let's get our word in
here anyway welcome everybody beautiful
Monday yeah it's hot it's hot you know
there's like a historic Heat Wave going
on in Europe
yeah shout out to our European uh
friends I hope you guys are doing okay
out there 100 degrees in London today
which is like unheard of unheard of less
than one percent of people in the UK
have air conditioner that yeah that's
the crazy thing
is that in Europe most of Europe they
don't have AC it just does not get that
hot there
so when it's 100 degrees
that might not sound like crazy to you
if you're in LA or Texas or a lot of
places sure that's right over here if
you don't have the infrastructure to
deal with 100 degree heat a lot of
people are going to die just straight up
lots of old people specifically
map shows devastating scale of wildfires
across Europe dang
this is not good guys
this is climate change my friends in
action and it's going to get worse and
worse and worse Italy's getting ravaged
what's going on down there
so sheesh Louise man it's crazy it's
getting all of us climate change is
literally going to destroy our habitable
beautiful Earth for ourselves nothing is
on fire I repeat nothing I hate to break
with you but pull up that map again
there Dan just information yeah that's
that's I'm sorry but I gotta call you
out
according to this
in 2009 it says fewer than five percent
of All European households have air
conditioning compared to 90 percent of
America okay shout out America you know
say what you will number one once again
you know say what you will but we got AC
motherfas five percent differences
astronomical
ninety percent of Americans have AC
that's pretty baller dude
now ironically the energy use of all of
that air conditioning is what's causing
wow so but at least we're cool while
we're doing it
is it is it that bad the the pollution
from AC I'm being yeah
I'm sure it doesn't help because I'm
pretty sure the majority of waste is
from
fossil Fields I don't think they burn
fossil fuels for energy that much
anymore do they
like I don't think so yeah there's still
lots of cool plants I think a lot really
yeah that's not yeah baby
it's a little ironic then I guess burn
the cold to cool the room
[Music]
uh air conditioning requires a lot of
energy to function properly they
consumes so much electricity and
therefore releases pollution well I know
it really excessive use of air
conditioning emits greenhouse gases that
are harmful to environment I know that
but the question is how much how we talk
how much are we talking about
fossil fuels 60 percent
but
of which 21 of that is uh cold yeah
that's that's pretty bad oh man Natural
Gas
[ __ ] you guys
we gotta do something what are we gonna
do about this in the words of how what
are we gonna do what are we going to do
about it what do we do about this oh bro
I just love that our effect our elected
representatives are like that's fine
it's fine
it's all good they're like let's just
let China deal with it what do we do
about it dude China is actually doing
way better than us on Renewables isn't
that kind of sad
uh well I mean they're I don't think
they're there yet uh but they are
investing dude they're they're going all
in on the renewable things I mean so
were most of the countries in Europe and
Europe yeah everyone's actually
making a decent effort but America in
fact our wonderful Supreme Court just
said it's illegal for the EPA to
regulate uh uh pollutions because we
believe in Freedom in this country I
believe in Freedom yeah an apple pie and
burning cold in July
that's a myth
burning trash on the neighborhood making
sure your grandma dies of asthma
[Applause]
that's America
California's on fire
Europe is on fire too yeah
Florida's underwater
and a Antarctica is melting
profound see old partners by the way
China is leading in renewable energy
production it currently is the world's
largest producer of wind and solar so I
guess shout out China there we go they
they are taking it seriously over there
I mean they are I believe the biggest
polluters still no maybe that stuff yeah
or one of those countries no I think the
per capita is it America's still number
one but really
um shout out dude that's America
burning trash outside
China's first and then America well they
have a China has like yeah it's Chinese
three billion people or something insane
or like one and a half bills one and a
half billion um their populations yeah
more than ours uh 4.35 times as much as
the US yeah so
but at least they're trying [ __ ] you
know what I mean and I mean the flip
side of that is too that China is you
know the factory for the world so it's
like that's fair they're putting out all
this emission but they're using those
that energy to make stuff that we then
buy it's all interconnected you can't
really like look at any one country it's
not really that's true
but I just appreciate that they're
actually doing something about it I mean
one good thing I can say is like in LA
at least I see I'm seeing so much more
um electric cars I don't think
unfortunately that's gonna make a huge
difference unless like every car's
Electric
but um it's a good thing that c you know
it's sad that people will have demonized
nuclear power I think nuclear power
could save the [ __ ] world
but everybody thinks it's evil even
though it's like almost zero emission
[ __ ] Infinite Energy isn't that right
nuclear power rules dude
you know something you guys have out
here that I haven't heard of Pryor's
emissions tests we have them in Michigan
but they're not required oh oh like the
smog test I had no idea what that was
when I moved out here interesting that's
been around forever because the thing
was in LA
back in the 90s and 2000s the air
quality here was like deadly terrific
since since there's been a lot of
regulations the air quality in La is
incredibly improved um actually yeah I
mean it's still smoggy here but good if
you look at picture much better from
like the 80s and early 90s uh it was
disgusting dude no the air quality in La
was like dangerous oh wow you know
kind of like what you think about in
China and some cities where it's
you pulling up photos Dan yeah yeah also
the gas pumps they're different out here
I didn't know how to use it at first
when we first moved here what's
different you're supposed to push the
button no it's like you got to put more
Force into it and like other states that
I've been to just put it in heavy Goosey
yeah loose yeah it just goes right in
yeah this is what La look and definitely
likes photos from the 70s that's like
there's a fire you know there's a
Perpetual fire happening yeah yeah
that's scary
but you know
I just really hope that um
man it's just crazy I wish somebody in
charge cared about this [ __ ] it's crazy
dude our country's so [ __ ] bro let's
get neurodivergent
Joe Biden's like let's get
neurodivergent no more like the Supreme
Court let's get nerve Divergent in here
let's get neurodivergent in here
doesn't really have the same ring to it
from being I'm doing the best like I
know you're you're trying it's not a
let's get restarted yeah
uh well anyway uh anyway uh happy Monday
uh on Adrian
donated 50 and said I'm a condensed
matter physicist bruh why are you
watching this show Gordon Freeman
uh and it frustrates me that people are
just going to assume science will come
up with some invention to save everybody
like covid hate to say it but it doesn't
look like we'll be able to fix the issue
yeah uh
yeah well based in black pill yeah
[Music]
um fecal matter
um coal well the good news is guys um
there is some science that's happening I
wanted to show you guys this
is the Arby's meat Mountain that we
preserved in epoxy what do you call this
resin resin resin can you find out when
we actually
um took the holy dip
and so this is the meat Mountain from
Arby's it has
chicken bacon uh roast beef
cheese
and it's an Abomination against against
God in fact that rabbit I feel it's
sacrileged to have the rabbit so close
to the meat Mountain it's like it's like
a black hole of animal Slaughter it will
suck in the rabbit and add him to the
meat Mountain
the current uh
wildfires and climate change is actually
punishment from God for for this well it
you know the meat mountain is is doesn't
help yeah it does not help at all and
yet here it is it is in perfect
condition one year strong this thing is
perfectly preserved wow and it's solid
my question and maybe that particle
physicist can answer it
you know Adrian let us know
um
you know people are always finding these
like preserved Amber with Prehistoric
bugs and [ __ ] that's like hundreds of
millions of years old can this resin
last that long
because
I would love for future societies to dig
this up and just ask what the [ __ ]
[Music]
can you imagine that they're taking DNA
samples from this and being like trying
to recreate our culture from this [ __ ]
like an artist Jurassic Park exactly
yeah once all of the uh
once we're in the post-apocalyptic
Wasteland and all these animals are
extinct and civilizations being rebuilt
200 years from now they'll be able to to
clone a nice little farm for chickens
and cows
what's important is that what this is is
the Rosetta Stone of fast food in the
future they will be able to have
another's meat Mountain if they play
their cards right Mad Max Meat Mountain
yes sir you know so this this to me is
very important this is a relic of
of Who We Are
you know how they have like that seed uh
somewhere in like uh seed Vault yeah in
the Iceland I think like an eye and a
frozen tundra they have underground a
seed Vault where they have every seed
um in this Library my seed is all over
this place [ __ ] that is such a gross
sound bite dude
is he really saying what I think he is
saying yeah what's the context of that
you said seed man I think it was uh no
he means what was the context of the
original clip wasn't it um he was moving
out of the uh that's so gross the like
gambling house or whatever yeah he was
living in that's just that sucks in the
treehouse
we might see it is everywhere bro don't
talk [ __ ] about your best your bestie
though listen we're making me well
Jeff's my bestie Banks didn't wasn't
even close he wasn't even in the running
was he but um you know I'm gonna add
this to the seed Vault so that in the
future people can
clone these you think it will rot in the
resin Amy I'm saying that yeah anywhere
bacteria could grow
um but there's no Oxygen
it's
it's still reach I'm guessing I'm
looking right here it says some foods
will rot quicker like strawberries but
yo this thing has not changed appearance
in a year dude if there was a bacteria
in here it would have got it by now the
way we could clean off the resin and you
could eat it I was thinking about that
that was another thought I had when we
first did that I asked that to Sam and
she's like nah that'll that'll probably
kill you
because the resin itself yeah toxic but
um
will definitely Outlast us no worries oh
yeah your legacy will live on that's
right
but um
don't you think of what it's like it
hasn't decomposed at all and it's been a
year incredible yeah I don't know
incredible website says food will
decompose but a body won't
how would they know that what I don't
know that's a weird thing to assert yeah
what's the name of that website
necrophilia.org
salvagesecrets.com oh that's the one I'm
on too what is the switch site glad you
said that a lot of it anyway I just want
to give a shout out and of course you
know who did this Sam
who is always yeah
producing these incredible uh wonders
so stand up Sam she's not here you're
not here she's not here
love you're here
I am yes what happened are you okay
uh should I be honest I'll be honest
yeah I was taking a nap and I don't care
I'm not mad I just I was worried about
you yeah I know I'm all good I was
taking a nap because my sleep schedule
is super wonky I had a kebab earlier and
that [ __ ] made me made me sleepy dude so
good
yeah I don't know good that's the first
time that ever happened yeah no you you
are usually very prompt love was just a
little we were about to go live and he
was still not around and we were all a
little worried about him because that's
not like him no that called me okay good
that's that woke us up now what time is
it there just to give people some
context it's a half past ten yeah so
there you have it it's pretty wild for
for poor love here
um thank you
anyway I'm glad you're okay listen um
there's actually a remake of Jurassic
Park going on it's called Uh Mountain
Park
it's called meat Park
me Mountain I think leave Mountain Park
exciting stuff guys
it's called Old McDonald's Farm
and it's just a farm
incredible stuff we can keep
workshopping one day
anyway
listen guys
through until midnight on Wednesday
we are still having our end of the world
sale Teddy fresh
50 off every goddamn thing on the
website guys
pettyfresh.com here's your opportunity
50 if you've wanted Teddy fresh
I know things have gotten really
expensive but hopefully now if you ever
wanted it you have a chance to grab some
50 off everything the classic color
block hoodies Looney Tunes collab
reverse fleece
and just a bunch of really there's a ton
of stuff on here
Gila Klein original
there's still some sizes left
you know
um there's a lot of great stuff at
teddyfresh.com 50 off
you have until the end of day on
Wednesday
to get hooked up so many great options
here guys I invite you to just go scroll
the page and see
some Elton John swag
surprised there's any of this left dude
Elton John swag
officially endorsed by Elton John
himself he saw the collection he says he
loves it
how about data
you shall be addressed by his proper
title Sir Elton John
he's a knight yeah well I'm not [ __ ]
English so I don't even need to say sir
do I excuse me sir excuse me sir wow
there you disrespect Sir Elton like that
listen I love Elton those I'll call I'll
put sir on his name I'll respect him
yeah but anyway guys check it out you
know now's a good time
to get hooked up well
what do we got here today I've got
terrible news that's coming up a little
bit later and I frankly just hate to
even
go there yeah
oh boy
[Music]
I'm not ready to talk about it Zach it's
just we can do it later
yeah well let's start with some good
news which is Wendy Williams and Vin
Diesel both have a birthday today
whoa so go let the pause so let the
conversation begin
happy birthday to vindi Williams
I almost was a sitter oh what a beauty
the new host
of Wendy Williams sharing a birthday
Vinnie Williams wow
it's been only three years apart I find
that insane
you think that Wendy looks older
they're just from different dimensions
but you know Vin is like a chain smoker
too yeah I think
oh no that makes sense to me Wendy
doesn't look that old she's just a
little yeah puffy from all the
surgeries
[Music]
just saying talk to me baby talk to me
baby
if if Vin Diesel hosted Wendy what would
be their chant because Wendy's was like
so what was this family
okay family family family family
just saying just saying
I have the great luxury of coming
I just got a text speaking of global
climate change I just got a text from
energy California
our pal we need to avoid outages let use
less energy at home from four to nine
how about you suck my dick Gavin Newsom
I'm just kidding
how dare you text me [ __ ]
hmm
[ __ ] you dude I'm ready to let the world
burn for that AC
yo guys Howie Mandel is still out here
we did this without wearing protection
and my wife is now so he's leaning into
it
I think he's trying to play it down like
I meant to do that but even as
disgusting as this is and it is funny
this is not the same as posting a
prolapse Howie we will never forget what
you did
in fact all the comments say
this turned into a meme I will not
forget what do we do about it Howie
needs his phone stolen bro
these people are soft dude
this Pro like I get it it's disgusting
but anybody that grew up with with 1999
to 2005 internet has seen way worse than
that bro this is not who's look this
these are these are unsuspecting victims
yeah it used to be a regular thing to
and it's how we made the looking at
[ __ ] goatsy and [ __ ] remember that it
was like everywhere yeah I do but this
isn't like a shock form this is Howie
Mandel Tick Tock I just get hungry when
I see the anus now just think of the
donut
yeah that donut was good anyway here's
here's Howie's new banger
which I will admit is funny
I did this without wearing protection
and my wife is now upset with me that's
why I bought a helmet
that's pretty wild Proclamation how in
the Dell ladies and gentlemen went up
the Hershey highway on his wife
and she [ __ ] herself apparently
like let's really unpack what he's
saying this without wearing protection
and my wife is now upset with me that's
why I bought a helmet so is he saying he
just slipped it in no consent somebody
know is this covid related he's really
just said he just went slipped at right
in on his wife I guess he didn't really
analyze yeah I didn't get that until
this moment but what else is he say I
was imagining that he just wasn't
wearing a condom but then I was like
he's probably been with his wife for
like a while why would you need a car
yeah right yes decades and like would
she be mad
I mean I guess it's their business anal
sex I wonder if how you will call in to
explain himself
we need an explanation on the uh what
did you do yeah what did you do Howie
you sick [ __ ]
and it's a sexual dance
but there you go where does he even find
these bro how he's on some weird Tick
Tock [ __ ] like the original video
this is it you know and how we found it
it made it his own it's not playing I
don't know why [ __ ] you tick tock
but anyway shout out ah you know what
I'm saying
that's what I'm talking about
yes sir
oh yeah
so now they're that's the show that's
all right thanks everybody it's a slow
weekend
newswise
I wish you guys this weekend by the way
I forgot to ask it's good just hung out
at home I'm still hungover good what you
were drinking Zach yeah
why uh chantal's cousins um 30th
birthday bash
so uh there was like a tequila squirt
gun yep yeah good times is that how you
use that mainly what you were consuming
is to Tequila's squirt gun yeah and you
know a bunch of beer and Claws and did
you puke or anything oh yeah oh really
oh yeah it was a spinning Kind of Night
and oh lovely Chick-fil-A before we went
to bed oh boy I would not to get too
graphic but the chicken was coming up I
can imagine yeah and it was like a chewy
thing sorry Olivia she can't do it oh
yeah I'm sorry did you make it to the
toilet or was it a mess no I made it to
the toilet okay I had the control but
yeah gnarly gnarly stuff
and with Chantelle equally drunk or was
she just judging you no no no no she
wasn't um she wasn't as uh schloth but
um we did Uber home okay I think he was
Squirt Gun you say yes sir so is this
like Super Soaker style yes
and do you like have somebody else at
the party shoot it into your mouth or is
it like kind of like a Kurt Cobain
situation
what
you're going around shooting in your
mouth you shoot your own mouth no no no
someone shoots there's a designated
shooter yeah okay are they uh more of a
Dodge it's more of a uh what was it were
the guys who all committed suicide and
went through yeah Heaven's Gates more of
a Heaven's Gate situation
I have a video of it
you have a video of it yeah I have a
video of it
okay if you want to see that yeah send
it to Dan we'll check it out
man I had a long weekend bro Theodore
he didn't poop for four days what's
going on with this kid in the poop
I don't know because he's taking like
stool softeners and stuff ever since he
got covered he's really been in a a
funky place that sucks and he didn't
poop for four days and then because it
hurts so much to poop he was unable to
pee for like 24 hours and it freaked me
the [ __ ] out and I was up with him all
night just trying to get him to go potty
I'm happy to say right before I left for
work today he did go poop and pee but
boy
long long time
it's been a long
July
the reason to believe this poop will be
softer than the last
[Laughter]
thanks Tim I appreciate that that was
funny yeah thank you
but you know everything's fine what the
good news is that one of my favorite
videos of all time we got a um a uh part
two
you guys remember this one
where
yeah the lady was stuck upside down
so look at this [ __ ]
now this may not look as bad to you a
bit but look at his feet and that's when
I really lose my mind you can see just
his feet flailing everywhere he is
completely lost control of that pod look
at his feet dude
that man is out of control
oh [ __ ] dude
like most people are just like wee nice
ride like there's one person getting a
little wild like down here they're going
sideways let's go
so is this a malfunction or do they have
explicitly
there's like this ride it has like a
little controller on it I don't think
it's wrong to do that
but like I'm wondering if he's
intentionally doing it or if his knee is
hit again exactly and like it's like a
chain reaction where the faster he spins
the more I don't think he is to
manipulate the uh rules I don't think so
because the first lady she was like
stuck upside she was falling out she was
scared for her life for sure and the way
his feet are flailing just makes me
think he's scared for his life right now
ow
what do we do about this do you know
like I don't see his hand on any kind of
lever or anything I just see a man
flailing for his life
right
there you have it
I mean okay it actually
it does look like he has one hand on the
control I gotta say it's his right hand
I don't know if you could pause it I can
try to pause it yeah
I think he might be doing it
intentionally maybe I mean it's funny
regardless but it looks like one of his
arms is sticking like straight out like
but the other one yeah I don't see how
see look he's wait is this like a
joystick thing so he's holding on to the
wing for Life yeah yeah it's advertised
as him doing it it says we salute this
Fearless Rider flipping their seat again
and again
I want a [ __ ] Legend
maybe he pretended like he did it on
purpose but there's yeah I meant to
there's no way the original lady meant
to do it but you should pull up the
original lady the original yeah hold on
let me let me get another look at this
because it does look like his hand is on
some kind of joystick but maybe the
pressure mounts so great that he can't
take he can't pull out the g-power shark
too great yeah he loses yeah so he's
holding on to something here
but once you get spinning maybe you
can't you can't shake out of it
laughs
but how come nobody else is even
spinning you know what I mean nobody
else is even taking the challenge
yet this guy
has gone Top Gun on it now this lady
this ain't right what happened to this
lady look at this [ __ ]
this is my favorite
this is my favorite video play that [ __ ]
again
oh God look at this she's dying
this is like there's something wrong
with this because that ride is not
equipped to hold you upside down she
could just fall right out yeah it looked
like she was really hanging on for dear
life like a B on the swings at Ace Fest
right
man that is funny
it's powerful it is it's powerful
anyway
there that is by the way Elon Musk
sex icon
why do the rich get everything they get
it all don't they
yeah taking a vacation on his yacht like
a humble King
I love it guys I sold all my houses bro
I don't you know I don't I don't believe
in material objects
vacationing on his super yacht
by the way there was some oh there was
some update on that by the way
somebody's showering them off what the
[ __ ] yeah he's getting hosed down like a
little piggy wait why are they hosing
him down you're in the ocean will you
take a shower to get the salt water off
of him it's not that weird take a shower
now boy hey squirt me off now come on
boy get in there deep that guy looks
like Brad the bull
sure does
yo oh I think we may need to investigate
who Grimes is the father of Brown's baby
really is with a bowl like that around
dude hairless King by the way a b um
your hair looks like Elon thoughts maybe
I'll be as wealthy as him one day maybe
you're one of us hello maybe maybe the
dude [ __ ] I have a little bit more color
than him though so that's true
the complexion really doesn't line up
yeah
look at this god-like body he actually
is not that in bad shape but I just love
how how are you hairlessly I don't
understand how that's possible man
doesn't have a single hair on those
suckable little nipples I mean he can
afford uh laser hair removal you think
he does that yeah probably that's
intense laser dude
I mean he got the hair transplant he's
definitely takes hair out how to puts
hair in yeah it all got moved up It's
All About Hair
in the life of the fabulously rich
wow though he got Joe Rogan nips kind of
huh
quite they're casting quite a shadow
they're very um
very wide
that's right there's a lot of distance
between them huh there's a lot of
the gap between the nips they've won the
Nobel Prize
wait Jeff Bezos also doesn't have hair
so at what point do you when you're a
billionaire do you lose all the hair on
your body
you got maybe some hairy nips going
dude why are these billionaires all
[ __ ] got this crazy ass body
what are they putting in what are they
doing Jeff looks good though no he looks
really good but like how old is he he's
a little swole
he's 58. I mean look at that that is
that is a good 58. that's not natural at
all it doesn't look natural it's got
like that swole yeah no this guy's all
the stem cells or something bro he might
be yeah he looks annoying it might be
hell yes this dude eats baby foreskin
from Korea for breakfast for sure
search for he he drinks spinal fluid it
eats four skin
definitely
that's a fact
oh that's a fact it's true I'm willing
to put that up there
you think this is whiskey no that's a
fermented baby uh uh uh
uh foreskin yeah yep
yep
the Bezos definitely waxes baby yeah I
mean that could I mean they're going out
on their yeah they didn't get waxed
beforehand I didn't realize Zuck was
there
I love how they're far they're washing
his ass off like a farm animal though
they look bigger they're also watching
uh Jeff Bezos off in the other photo at
least that's his like girlfriend doing
it why you can't wash yourself off Elon
you need this Brad the bull to do it
like at what point you're rich you're
too rich to wash yourself off
hmm yeah I would say that Jeff Bezos
transformation is one of the craziest I
mean elon's is crazy too dork ass
[ __ ] loser Lex Luthor I own this
world and everyone in it
crazy huh
look at this hell yes dark ass [ __ ]
beta
version
I literally [ __ ] your wife on the
wedding day
you think
and the windbreaker vest and the tight
jeans oh hell yeah bro that
windbreaker's beta as hell he doesn't
need sleeves what sleeve could even fit
on his biceps actually what's going on
look at the pants in the before picture
yeah he couldn't he couldn't afford
fitted pants because he's beta stylish
it's nice looking
yeah it's a little I mean there's a lot
of space a little baggy don't you think
and look how far up his sleeves are
rolled like the dude can't fit clothing
to his ass sure I think it's ripped out
honestly
okay I gotta agree with love there I
don't think this outfit's very drippy
just to be frank but I respect your guys
opinion thank you you know uh oh here's
besties um we're both hanging out
together
on the yacht I'm wearing a diaper I'm
good he's wearing a towel
you know what it is
you know the Vibes you know the Vibes
come on now
I thought I was a pasty ass looking [ __ ]
but I got like I look like a tanned
Legend compared to him it's a Vibe right
now
yep
I'm gonna rip a dart dude
oh that's anyway yeah we love body
shaming billionaires I mean it's kind of
he's the richest man in the world folks
he can take it that those nipples cast a
shadow that uh
makes the Statue of Liberty a Cry tears
of fascism you can tell the time with
his nips oh yeah little sundials there
yeah
looks about to be 12 o'clock by the
shadow
oh God yo when you ask Elon what time it
is he he looks he takes a hold on
oh yeah we love that for him funny
he keeps it analog dude with those nips
if his nibs could tell the time the
Rogan Snips could tell the end of times
oh
what happens if Doomsday Clock yeah
exactly yo what happens if there's
nipples touch
it's like a matter of fact matter and
anti-matter they annihilate one another
ah
I think they'll create a spark
a little spark a little drop of milk
maybe a little magic
magic so lots of good stuff happening
real quick shout out Rory Hicks for 200
dollars
in the Super Chat said uh from the mole
people the mole oh
the mole people uh who live underground
have um thank you bro discover the
History Podcast and they're donating so
thank you thank you bro and this weekend
by the way to all of our beautiful
members that we're going to try to do
the tippy toes
someone's birthday is it your birthday
Dad we have two birthdays actually
um wait whose birthday Dan and cameras
up this weekend Dan cam birthday
spectacular featuring the tippy toes
roll of a lifetime
yes it's gonna be fun so shout out all
members every time we talk about this I
see a substantial amount of people that
uh
seemingly
maybe they're newer fans and don't
remember all the conversations about
tiptoes
um yeah we got claimed for showing this
trailer can you believe that so oh we
did I was gonna say maybe we should
watch the trailer but I guess oh well
listen it's like the most insane movie
ever with like super star cast and it's
a story oh Matthew McConaughey and Gary
Oldman and he starts dating a girl and
her whole or no a girl starts dating
Matthew McConaughey but there's one
crazy catch all of his family
and I use I know this is a drugstore
work but I think it's what they say in
the trailer are midgets yes
he's like all your family is what
and uh Gary Oldman is walking around on
his knees the whole time pretending like
he's a little person and they say and
the role of a lifetime Gary Oldman nuts
so another detail is the main character
Matthew McConaughey he only tells his uh
girlfriend that his family is uh
Little People Little People yeah because
she's pregnant and he feels like she has
to know because the child oh you know
what I think that's I think I I think
it's fair to be upset that not not
because there's anything wrong but like
why didn't you tell me sooner well I
think even more than that
it we haven't seen it yet but in the
trailer they're getting married they're
not just boyfriend girlfriend they're
engaged and he takes her to a dinner to
meet his family and doesn't tell her
what she's about to walk into and so
she's like why didn't you never mention
that your entire family or little people
that's fair it does seem pretty weird
yeah
significant other that everyone in your
family's a little person you disagree
Olivia I see you're thinking about it
like should they should they tell you I
think I'm just in terms of like to be
aware yeah just in terms of like an
intimate relationship where you don't no
I agree we're gonna go we're gonna go to
dinner and meet my family and then you
walk in and just everyone's like a
person yeah
right it's a little odd we'll see though
because it's more portrayed in the
trailer as like your family is what
right yeah it's very it's super
offensive and like Ethan said Gary
Oldman is on his knees the entire time
and just looks so insane the makeup is
terrible uh it's yeah so that's exciting
so this this weekend is going to be uh
yeah on Saturday we will be doing for
members only a reaction live stream
where we finally watch this movie that
we've been joking around for three years
about at this point
speaking of the heat wave in in Europe
there's some funny
um
media
UK Heat Wave they have on one window a
picture of the Sun a live stream of the
sun sun watch I'm not quite sure what
that's supposed to convey by the way I
don't think you're supposed to point a
lens at the sun really not great for the
sensor no but I love that and they're
like take a look at the sun today boys
and a reporter in a station holding a
giant thermometer so
top level reporting here folks
and today we cut to the sun sun what do
you think about this uh hot weather
all right thanks son back to her
love the comically I can't even tell
where it's not a great thing for
television I can't even tell where the
line is at yeah
where's the line I don't know how hot it
is yeah how much oh look at the Sun
yeah huge huge hard-hitting news there
oh you know this is actually crazy it
got so hot in Britain that they had to
close the Royal Air Force uh base the
largest base because the runways were
melting
that's kind of odd 100 degrees and they
melt or they just built from or do we
just build them different here
yeah I would imagine so
let's just bring you some breaks
[ __ ] you still have the sun live
stream of the Sun
what am I supposed to do with that what
if something changes with it what are
they waiting for to explode or something
what if it like says something
that's great what the hell dude
yeah
the RAF has halted flight in and out of
RAF Bryce Norton because
the runway has melted in this extreme
weather now Bryson is in Oxfordshire
it's the largest RAF base in the country
and another source has been telling Sky
News this afternoon that I can't stop
staring at the sun Kim
don't do that
you've never seen hard granted to ensure
that there is no impact on any military
operations today
good time to invade England it sounds
like
you know what I'm saying if anyone out
there was planning it
but yeah I think I think we have
different asphalt and [ __ ] here because
our asphalt be melting too dude
before 85 degrees Yeah RS4 our asphalt
don't melt in that kind of heat bro we
we just do things different here in
America I remember like in on hot summer
days I used to sit and like pick on the
asphalt because it was soft with frogs
whoa yeah I guess you guys just has more
rubber or something
I think yeah possibly
there's probably a balance between like
it's more durable with more rubber but
it melts at lower temperatures and
they're like ass doesn't get ever
getting 100 degrees here
well that's interesting
oh God this clip reminded me of UAB
this scared the [ __ ] out of me yeah you
can tell me okay because this I watched
this and I was so frustrated watching
this Lena have you seen this clip
no I haven't okay because I was curious
for you to kind of give feedback about
how your guys's experience with a B
choking compares to this but let me play
it
um is this hard for you to watch Amy
uh
no
but I wish mine was this tame yeah baby
sounded a lot worse so yours was crazier
than this oh a lot yeah a lot right here
so so there's no projectile vomiting
yeah but this guy needed a heimlich to
survive
yeah
this guy didn't breathe at all for like
two minutes
I just it's like oh man
so he's choking his Airways completely
clogged what really frustrate me is how
you'll see everyone in the restaurant it
starts just watching him waiting for him
to die and nobody's doing a damn thing
to help the man
also he just seems remarkably
lost too
I saw some people messaging me saying
that a lot of people actually die in the
restroom because they're embarrassed to
make a scene so they go to the restroom
and end up choking to death oh that's
what I was what I was just thinking is
uh it seems like he was embarrassed and
didn't want to yeah for real when he was
he decided to like walk back but it
looked like he was going to the back at
a certain point I thought he was going
to go to the bathroom and I could see
that he may have died there yeah so the
manager comes out
absolute Chad yeah get him bro
get him dude get in there
there you go you got it Lafayette backs
up real quick 90 seconds this guy
couldn't breathe man
that's why we got to learn the Heimlich
you want to be a Chad when this stuff
happens
yep
yeah Sizzler they they didn't want to
help I think they were afraid that uh
they're already not doing well I'm
guessing business-wise and if someone
dies there it may completely kill the
business so they just ran into the back
I think they're waiting for me to die
and they're just gonna hide the body
the people run to the back yeah there
was there was a way there was two
waiters that went to the back they just
ran from you were they trying to get out
no one didn't want to do it I mean they
didn't run but they just walked to the
back and they never came back okay we
were there for a while tell me how did
your experience differ from this one I
mean you could breathe a little bit
right
uh at first I couldn't know at first I
couldn't at all so I and I tried
drinking any every time I tried drinking
the water I would project it like
violently spitting it everywhere
everywhere on the table on the floor on
my phone and everyone just looking at me
there's like a buffet by me everyone's
like stopping looking at me and still
putting their food
it was yeah I thought um this video was
going to be the same thing as what
happened to AB because he stood up like
that and kind of like paced a little bit
back and forth but and the interviewer
was looking at him but nobody helped him
and talina's credit she got up
immediately and started slapping my belt
okay it didn't help but she yeah that's
good yeah
wow
so you do you know how to give yourself
the Heimlich now like love said you can
jump on the table Yeah slam your stomach
yeah anyways you could do it yeah you
could do it like the way you do it with
two people but by yourself right or you
could do it on a Surface like a table or
a chair but are you prepared if this
happens again you guys I want to make
sure that you guys I hope so I have a
doctor's appointment coming up on my
time to look at my esophagus okay a lot
of people and thank you guys so much A
lot of people have been recommending
that I get looked at
um some people even paid for cameos to
send me messages oh my God help me out
yeah
very sweet
can't wait to report your death I mean
one only the other thing that could be
more embarrassing than what you went
through is slamming yourself into the
table oh yeah but you got to save your
life bro yeah
Lena I thought I was done because like I
I got it to a point where I could at
least breathe a little bit and that's
when I sat down and like Lena's like are
you done look am I done eating and then
uh asked if I wanted to pack up the food
but I love you guys took us to go and
you were still dying
did you guys eat the leftovers no so I
was going to pull it out some people
said My Story was fake I guess what yeah
we had the proof at home because we had
a full steak and a Sizzler uh bag but
did you ever eat it no Lena tossed it
I didn't know you would want it he asked
me for it the other day and I'm like
what of course I threw it away I didn't
think you'd actually want it he was so
disappointed yeah yeah
it would have been funny if you ate it
and choked again though
that would be [ __ ] awesome
the next day Lena almost choked I don't
know we had a bad weekend we had a bad
yeah
that's just yeah
anyway you know you okay you almost
choked too it wasn't as bad but yeah I
was okay
what the [ __ ] bro I thought this title
would be at an exaggeration but it's not
meanwhile on Facebook
the Facebook video economy is Alive and
Well my friends oh yeah this is called
um this video is called
the most beautiful thing I've ever seen
today
it has four million likes and 88 million
views watch how this starts
this is the most beautiful thing I've
seen today
bro forcibly
kidnapping him
what the [ __ ]
I probably all have gloves on too it's a
prank bro
yo what but you know what like house
it's so scary to be homeless because
people can do whatever they want to you
even if it's like forcing you to get a
haircut for their video that guy thought
you were gonna do like tortures and
experiments on them I mean
why is everyone think this is like okay
Behavior
they gave him a haircut
they're just he's just gonna go back on
the street
they're showering him Jesus his clothes
are all wet now
oh my god do they give him new clothes
yeah okay good
at least that
he looks actually looks pretty good now
they should have just told him before
what they were doing
and the one makes such a good video
all right see you bro enjoy have a good
night's sleep on the street
he doesn't want to leave
I'm gonna pull him back out CEO Partners
get the [ __ ] out yo this is like this is
the trashiest [ __ ] ever these guys
didn't even make an attempt to actually
improve his life at least like on
YouTube they like I'm gonna buy you a
hotel for an eye I'm gonna take you out
for a nice meal they're just like [ __ ]
no bro you're getting kidnapped it's
bucketed down
it's a prank bro we're buzzing your head
like the army
look at this you can't just do that you
can't just forcibly kidnap people and
throw them in the back of your car
[ __ ]
so there you go Facebook my friends 88
million views
the most beautiful thing I've seen today
isn't that awesome four million likes on
this [ __ ] video bro
not let's read the comments what's so
beautiful like okay so someone gets it
16 000 likes what's so beautiful they
kidnapped the guy and force watched him
like an animal and then they just put
him back on the street and put it on
Tick Tock reviews
if they really wanted to help him there
are other less humiliating ways shut up
Rachel
this is the most beautiful thing I've
seen today
stupid ass a libtard
so touching to see how they kidnapped an
old man forced washed him got views and
then kicked him back on the streets
this is the most beautiful thing I've
seen today
somebody donated two dollars and said
talk about Rogan saying shoot the
homeless say what did he say is that a
new tech it's news to me that's an
interesting platform
killed the homeless kill kill kill the
poor nobody's run on that yet
Rick Caruso almost practically that's
his body yeah that pretty much is his
platform actually I guess it's not that
burn the homeless into horse glue
I wonder if Rogan will move back if Rick
uh wins
look at God won't he blessing to those
angels that helped and took the time to
show kindness
you can't be serious bro
God I I'm not even sure that this kind
of content would not be removed on
YouTube today which is a good thing
let's all be frank about that and but on
Facebook man you can even live stream
yourself shooting up places YouTube
would remove this I don't know I do I do
I think they would
help let's see helping
almost people I bet there's a clip right
but if it was going Mega viral I think
they would punish the channel
because like
okay wait
nothing like a couple of rich [ __ ]
sitting around smoking cigars and
criticizing people at the rock bottom
and the last line maybe you should just
get shot okay Joe let's see what what's
going on here
and then uh we're on the underpass and
there's porta potties not one either
like four like a deck of portable
potties and then someone has a car
parked there on the sidewalk I recognize
that particularly on the sidewalk so
they're like half blocking a lane and
then they have like a canopy draped over
their car and they have just stacks of
[ __ ] and then next to it was a dresser
they had a dresser Jesus so they had
their shoes and a shoe is that the dicey
no Brendan Schwab no that sounds like
sagura to me that's yeah oh no not my
boys to girl it was a shoe rack I love
sugar I won't could say anything about
him like this is where they live that's
really wild I didn't it's Tommy's just
agreeing with him what's he gonna say
you know I don't know I haven't seen
this clip no also that
um
you know when when you see stuff like
that on the streets at least in Los
Angeles or maybe in California those are
that's protected property like by law
you know that like if you were not
supposed to do that but and but like
that's that person's property by law oh
the homeless person is probably
protected I mean are we against that
absolutely
huh if you were to go and try to move
that or take that you'd get arrested
yeah
yeah hilarious but they wouldn't arrest
you if you shot somebody
maybe should just go and shoot the
homeless people I like your ideas wait
wait wait how did he get from waiting
homeless are we did I miss something I'm
seeing this was posted on our sub
yesterday and it was deleted and
everyone's saying that it was a joke
yeah he's joking but what's the how did
they make that leap
yes absolutely huh if you were to go and
try to move that or take that you'd get
arrested yeah
yeah hilarious but they wouldn't arrest
you if you shot somebody
maybe she just go and shoot the homeless
people I like your ideas yeah and if
nobody claims it I mean nobody does
anything about violent crime in L.A
anymore it's a [ __ ] joke what is this
they're just letting be Joe Rogan's such
a dumb [ __ ] dude I love it he moves to
Texas and like now it's like [ __ ] a
little bro
[ __ ] homeless people and it's all
violence there bro
yeah I don't think that they'll just let
you murder homeless people I mean I know
he's maybe joking I didn't really seem
with what he says afterwards it doesn't
sound like he is joking he seems to
think that nobody gets prosecuted for
prosecuted for uh murder well he's not
working this now he dude if he thinks
that's crazy he should see what what
happened in Uvaldi hmm yeah a city in
Texas where he lives that he loves so
much I said you valdi
remember what happened there
by the way speaking of Uvalde 400 cops
they now report
400 [ __ ] cops were outside
that's like a whole Battalion dude
[ __ ]
400 brave warriors do you know what the
police need more funding
450 maybe if there were 800 cops they
could have stopped you they're a little
understaffed yeah exactly we need more
police they need more funding we need
more police and we need more equipment
yeah there was only 400 cops there at a
small town in Texas a bunch of [ __ ]
foreign
400 cops dude
holy yeah yeah boy you guys are not
tough enough that's enough cops to take
over a damn take over the house of
Congress
you know how many dogs 400 cops could
kill
how many dogs yeah
I don't know dozens thousands yeah
thousands
I don't understand this hate against
homeless people though that Joe Rogan he
goes on and on and on about homeless uh
and it's like bro what do you want
they're [ __ ] homeless they have
nothing they have no options they're
literally just surviving you should be
mad at the government you should be mad
at our
you know our systems have failed we have
failed them as yeah society and by the
way Joe Rogan you're worth like several
hundred million dollars like you are one
of the few people in this world that's
in a position to actually do something
and helpful about it
but meanwhile you're you're endorsing uh
Rick Caruso whose platform is basically
shoot the homeless
did he endorse Rick pretty sure he did
probably
their views seem to align pretty pretty
good yeah I mean homelessness is
obviously it's a it's a symptom and you
know getting I mean
yeah nobody nobody likes having nobody's
in their City yeah yeah
it's awful most of all them
right and that's
something blaming them and just saying
the solution is to just shoot them is uh
dude they're the most powerless it's
kind of psycho disenfranchised
people in the whole country
but I think if we had more police we
might actually get to the bottom of this
right I think we need a hundred thousand
police officers in downtown L.A
and tanks potentially
and maybe just put them in the Army
Overkill no no just just some M raps
just some uh just some uh apcs you know
I think tanks okay full blown put them
in Army outfits right okay
and um maybe just don't let people
outside at night also like a curfew
right
and uh mass incarceration
maybe just take maybe just overthrow the
government
and uh do airstrikes from Apache
helicopters at night
there you go shadow
um to Joe Rogan folks
Bastion of
I thought by the way you know we have a
thing for people falling off the stage
this is one of the best I've seen the
cameraman falls off the stage oh that's
bad
oh he nuts himself so good there holy
[ __ ]
oh that is brutal dude that's a risky
job the guy can't even look at what is
going on
oh I felt that one how much do you think
that camera costs too I was just gonna
ask Dan uh
can you pause it right when it starts
yeah yeah
hang on and get a nice shot at that can
you see anything interesting there
it's not like maybe a juicy cam Sony f55
or something like that
it's expensive yeah that's for sure
uh so there you have it the f55 is uh
retails at thirty thousand so thirty
thousand let's go I'm right about it
being that it's I could definitely be
wrong it just kind of looks like that
wait let's not Philip DeFranco is it no
no he's sexy Phil that was sexy that's
sexy Phil the [ __ ]
shout out to the artist that actually
stopped singing instead of just keep
going yeah that was that was kind of
nice of him yeah
Travis Scott would have spit on him he's
like bro I just got with like WWF elbow
bombed him
oh it's got to be 30 minutes by now
right Dan it is definitely it's way over
let's let's do some ads baby thank you
to Honey [ __ ] honey yeah
today's episode episode is sponsored by
Honey the easy way to save when shopping
on your iPhone or computer
I save so much money on honey ELO shops
online a lot and these are all coupons
we've saved
passively from doing nothing five bucks
there's got there's got to be crazier
ones than that I just think this one's
that's 33 that's 30 that's a good
discount I mean we've saved hundreds of
dollars on
yeah uh here here's one 200 bucks yeah
um
this happens pretty much every time I
shop these days is you get a honey
coupon you know thanks to Honey manually
searching for coupon codes is a thing of
the past honey is a free shopping tool
that scours the internet for promo codes
and applies the best when it finds your
card imagine you're shopping at one of
your favorite sites and when you check
out the honey button appears and all you
got to do is Click apply coupon wait a
few seconds as honey searches for
coupons that can find for that site it
finally finds a working coupon you're
gonna watch that price drop magically
let's go you don't have to think about
it I think this was a couch or something
or a chair I think it's a rug or there
you go rug
rocks are expensive man yeah what the
hell
it's too gross
yo did you really spend two thousand
dollars on a rug yeah but chill it's
gonna cringe
hosting our L's no she saved almost 200
bucks oh that's true let's go let's go
honey let's go
yeah but it's honestly insane I mean it
works on Tech Furniture even Postmates
um
Shopping Club I mean it's everywhere
dude and G fuel G fuel even uh there you
have it
I got it right here
um honey doesn't just work on desktop
now it also works on iPhone too just
activated on the Safari app on your
phone and save on the go if you don't
already have honey you could be straight
up missing out on savings and by getting
it you'll be helping yourself and
helping this show thank you very much I
use honey all the time I have it on all
my browsers I highly recommend it get
honey for free at joanhoney.com h3tv
that's joinhoney.com
h3tv thank you thank you
and finally thank you to Babel let's go
listen
you going to Spain you go into Italy
you're going to Mexico going to Germany
get on that babble brush UPS on some
talking skills and I'll tell you that
experience is going to be a lot more
enriching for you for all your summer
travels or France
for all your summer travels whether
you're going abroad or staying domestic
I want to immerse yourself in the
culture and now is the perfect time to
start babble babbles the language
learning app that sold more than 10
million subscribers and thanks to
Babel's addictively fun and easy
bite-sized language lessons there's
still time to learn a new language
before you reach your destination
uh Ian is practically fluent in French
by now thanks to Babel
we
excellent pronunciation thank you what
now see Miss oh that is good
pronunciation
um
but how is the Babel it has like fun
games addictive it's pretty fun right
Ian
yeah I've been babbling all over the
place man I love it
thanks
wow
she looked it up I have tried it at the
games and the way that they teach is
super fun honestly and really effective
in fact with battle you only need a 10
minutes to complete a lesson so you can
start having a real life conversation in
new languages in as little as three
weeks
other language learning apps use AI for
their lesson plans but Babel was created
by 150 language experts their teaching
methods have been scientifically proven
to be effective and with Babel you can
choose from 14 different languages
including Spanish French Italian and
German
plus Babel's speech recognition
Technologies helped you improve your
pronunciation and accent there's so many
different ways to learn with Babel in
addition to lessons you can access
podcast Games videos stories and even
live classes plus it comes with a 20-day
back money guarantee
uh our 20-day money-back guaranteed
start your new language learning Journey
today with Babel right now save up to 60
off your subscription when you go to
babble.com
h3tv that's babble.com
h3tv for sixty percent off your
subscription Babble it's language for
life thank you thank you to the
beautiful folks at Babel
love that for them
[Music]
okay so we have some Cobra Tate updates
but I saw in the subreddit there was did
you guys see that that there was some
debate over whether
yeah people don't like Cobra Well yeah I
mean he's like literally the worst
person but like they don't even like us
making fun of him seemingly
that was what I was at least some people
I should say I'm sure we should take a
poll because sometimes it's hard to tell
um what's real or what's not
but you know I'll tell you we've dug up
Andrew Tate made music videos and I'll
tell you right now it's the worst
rapping I've ever seen and I'm a
YouTuber I've seen all the worst rap in
the world trust me they're out there
constantly
and Andrew Tate I think was so
embarrassed he actually erased these it
and they got dug up from the anals it's
weirder than that
cam randomly sent one of the music
videos the other day at like well it was
like in the morning right cam
essentially like 10 in the morning or
something and I saw the message at like
11 and clicked on it and the video was
private
yeah and then cam was like what the [ __ ]
that's weird and then I went on the way
back machine and this video had been up
for months for like years actually it
was posted in 2020 and an hour after cam
sent it to us it got privated after two
years of being online
that is a weird coincidence right it had
half a million views at the time yeah
[Music]
is he in our group chat
she knows somehow so they're molds he's
definitely under a lot of pressure and
he's well he's cleaning up everything
right like his website he took off like
oh I used to literally for a job sex
traffic women right so he he's been
scrubbing the internet of all his L's
right and cringe
um but listen I don't I'm not gonna
watch this if you guys well really well
like do you like us dunking on COBRA
Tate or just say do you should we watch
the videos or no I mean you know
I think people were more disturbed by
like the consistency of the things he
was saying and like how stupid it is
because it's all the same [ __ ] every
time that I kind of agree I'm curious to
see these videos because we've never
seen him rap before but it's the worst
dude he is so bad I really really want
to watch
um personally
people saying Razzle the worst no this
is worse than Razzle this is the worst
I've ever seen this is actually worse
the Razzle song was kind of a Bop wait
which one's Razzle like
[Music]
some big Instagram account the other day
what about her she's like her her sequel
to that song
no I can't believe YouTube would do that
they're out of control man
up high chin up high that's right here
it is China pie 1.5 million oh maybe
that's a great upload yeah
this was uploaded September 3rd to 2021.
okay so she got it reinstated maybe but
it only has 1.5 million views no I I saw
what Love's talking about I had a crazy
amount of views wherever it was removed
maybe it was a different platform Maybe
party all the time anyway
um oh oh I just realized I got confused
that's actually not the person they were
talking Razzle Khan was the crypto lady
remember the crypto rap the lady who got
arrested for like yes yes yes yes I'll
forgive me oh I did who did chin up high
then what's their name Amy Bonnie okay I
am so sorry to Amy for oh completing
this dude I'm so sorry a shout out to uh
Dan thank you
well we've got right now 70 saying let's
watch cover tape music video now I gotta
say I'm pretty surprised that even 27
are saying no
potentially even 30 percent
I'm over having to listen to a cobra
tape but I want to assure you
like we're not going to be engaging with
like him being like I think women should
be you know locked to uh yeah this is
kind of just pure cringe yeah it's not
like his ranting about the typical [ __ ]
and I think it's powerful I think this
is maybe his Kryptonite this is the fact
that he privated it he's hiding I think
that he might be embarrassed by this
which which is kind of Awesome
yeah but I'm not gonna be like so if
you're like Olivia said we're not
engaging with like
his uh insane takes we're just trying to
embarrass him now which is good that's
powerful right
um
so let's just do it then you know and
stick with this guys don't get
disheartened okay you're gonna love this
so his first music video is uh sugar
daddy
and um this [ __ ] is so brutal sounds
horrible this guy's a talent I mean I'm
surprised he hasn't been signed
I I always hear him say he's great he's
great at everything he's the best at
everything
so this should be one of the best songs
ever
here we go
um sugar daddy official music video
see if we get some closed captions too I
want to hear those bopping lyrics
they're Auto generated
bubble Walter
look good I don't want to lie you know I
wanna fight but I don't wanna whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa I already gotta stop here
I don't think I saw this one I saw the
other ones back the [ __ ] up Andrew
let's I got for a what
girl you look good
girl you look good I want to handcuff
you to my furnace
I'm above the lawn Romania
wanna lie you know I wanna fight but I
don't want to try I'll take you to Dubai
put you in the sky
put you in the sky that is so good oh
those Rhymes are insane
thank you
so this this isn't the one that he
privated right this one is still up on
his channel this morning he's proud of
this morning there were three up on that
uh Tate Clips Channel
all three of these videos are up there
including the one that he deleted
what was the one that was deleted
I have to look back at her chat by the
way people have been making fun of me
for the way I pour my sodas so gently
and I'm gonna tell you guys why
okay if you pour it in too aggressively
it loses all of its carbonation and it
tastes like [ __ ] wait people yeah people
are giving you [ __ ] for pouring it like
that yeah there's a problem that was
like here's Ethan pouring his Saudi for
20 seconds that's a proper poor people
okay thank you again I know I'm with you
yeah you gotta you gotta do the Tilt I
was I showed that clip to Lena I'm like
why did it take him so long she's like
she knew why because her dad does that
as well oh [ __ ] thank you Lena
she's take care of something downstairs
so nice of carbonated yeah especially if
you have ice in it yep dude it will go
flat immediately
so it's almost like pouring a beer it's
even more delicate yeah it is similar
though similar technique yeah
bubble soda all right bubble soda so
this ride's already thin I mean the song
Santa ten I need an Anthony fantano
review
see
they call me Mr plenty plenty check the
leather
your friends
[Music]
you know I know I know he thinks he's
like a babe and [ __ ] he actually is one
of the goofiest looking [ __ ] dudes
like honestly the man
is borderline like should be wearing a
helmet like looks like he should be
wearing a helmet
I mean look at his face dude
and I know why he's always wearing
glasses because he has kind of like
I I'm sorry and I I don't mean to be
offensive I only want to be offensive to
Andrew but it kind of has
um
Andrew kind of has birth defect eyes
and I just say that with peace and love
look at this idiot bro look at this
[ __ ] dumb goofy [ __ ] bro look at him
it's all the bubble water Bubble Up you
don't drink bubble water Ethan I don't
care if you don't drink bubble water
you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] look at this bait
a [ __ ] not drinking bubble water
if you're not secular assaulting women
you're a [ __ ] [ __ ]
look at this goofy face [ __ ]
also that that fate is kind of crazy
it's not that good dude
you look at your head looks like a Chia
Pet you [ __ ] loser
well he seems to have given up on that
battle he's embraced the dogs recent
months I've noticed so
yeah put a little soil and chia seeds up
on that [ __ ]
that's what it looks like Romania isn't
far from Turkey why doesn't he pop over
there and
get a little
little something something done up top
up turkey they call me Mr plenty plenty
check the leather on the Bentleys
[Music]
why does everyone want to be a rapper
it's like the stepping stone of every
[ __ ] douche no matter who it is
YouTubers
Truman traffickers everybody wants to be
a rapper everything in between and on
Disney Channel too I don't know if you
guys remember all the Disney Channel
actors all had their own rap songs was
that right
I actually have a rap song
the one I made about rice gum
uh yeah that's right kind of been
listening to that in a minute
you should pull that up let's see I want
to check my rap career real fast
too right did I make a sofa wrap I don't
remember with pose maybe oh no it's just
a stupid little okay yeah
[Music]
we come back
[Music]
uh
time for a second verse check it out
[Music]
bro oh my God it's a girl
is that his hard ass rap voice
oh my god dude you guys understand where
this all comes from it's deep deep
brutal
um debilitating insecurity
this man is so bitterly deeply insecure
but your girl tell me she's your friend
can you grab that sound bite of him
going it's your girl sure
[Music]
it's even deeper voice than Vinnie
diesel car I got money I can spend give
it a whirl I love two sugar babies I got
everything you need I can handle two
ladies look ladies in the back of my
Mercedes that's another reason
cause I've been getting money on The
Daily I can be a sugar daddy sugar lady
sugar lady up sugar lady sugar lady yup
I could be your sugar daddy sugar daddy
sugar lady yup
cause I'm All About The Money dude I
can't deal with your buddy again I can't
do another verse with him
bro you're really gonna close it out oh
my God
oh through University
bro I can't believe did you enjoy that
music video come and sign up for my
Ponzi scheme would you like to have a sh
oh this is interesting virgin Tate
versus Chad diesel oh so true yo look
how tiny the Virgin Tate is
you know Chad diesel pulls harder than
Tate though you know for sure
what
I mean do you remember that video talk
to me baby we mean consensually
you guys think it's a joke he's a little
pushy but as far as I know he's not an r
word
I wasn't implying that I wasn't playing
so he's a king compared to Tate right
well yeah he's a respectful King
compared to Tate over the human
trafficker yeah I guess it's all
relative that's a good question that's a
good question baby talk to me hey did
you find my rice gum yeah I sent it you
guys want to see my rap career
I did made one wrap against rice gum
look at this [ __ ] you all ready
oh wow this video got a lot of views I
love the YouTube royalty free yo this
was one of the um last videos I ever
made on the channel yeah that's true
2019
yeah has it been that long
almost 9 million views though what's up
dude people like my [ __ ] dude
what's up play didn't you do a rap for
the co-vidiots video too
cool videos yeah
um you made a video about the covet
idiots I could have sworn morons of
coronavirus yeah
dude I don't remember that at all if you
can timestamp I'll believe you but I
don't remember [ __ ] about it
all right guys here's a little up here's
a little scroll through my uh
music history okay
um you smell that yeah by the way this
beats straight out of free music library
yeah yeah and it's I recognize it it's a
sick beat to be honest yeah
smells like
fried rice okay
he loves Warren well let's start there
she's a self-made
millionaired her country made a company
and created to a new country she got in
the bag without selling her soul
and broke the mode
it was a mistake I should have done it
and it'll never happen again but [ __ ]
I made the bag bag
[ __ ] yeah but she got the back without
selling her soul
[Music]
this is embarrassing me
now let's talk about you rice you chase
Cloud to fill a hole in your soul
without substance you will disappear you
need love son I wish your mom would hear
your bitterness comes from the reality
that the most interesting thing about
you is your money I should have done it
and it'll never happen again but [ __ ]
I remember I was up to like 5 a.m
breading this all night I was all into
it and [ __ ] I'm embarrassed to watch
this now
wait I wanna
better than Andrew Tate at least damn
Gumby when you okay get out of here you
[ __ ] clown
[Music]
oh [ __ ] bro that beat goes so hard
though
Cobra Tate
human trafficker okay
yo where my girls at my mom didn't love
me now this is where I'm at my daddy
walked out so I'm insecure gonna lock
women up to my radiator put them on the
camera oh God
yo the U.S embassy is coming for me good
thing I'm in Romania and I'm above the
law I suck my brother's dick
but I don't talk about it bars let's go
yeah sign up for my [ __ ]
I got the goofiest face you've seen
that's why I wear glasses it's obscene
yeah bars okay okay
[Music]
wait I did another rap the [ __ ] are you
serious what was the context of this
toilet paper
I have no recollection of making this
video
look at the drip though holy moly holy
[ __ ] oh this outfit
oh what the [ __ ] I don't remember this
video it was like the first video like
right when we went into lockdown
Mike
covid covert make that booty hole score
you know that's why she likes me
young TP
I heard you got a Rolex Rolls Royce boy
that's nice but you can't even keep it
clean without that OxiClean
Purell and hope no money no clothes only
got Bros I did twice the first time it's
nice the second time was Santa watch
I'll roll back up you know what these
rap videos are fake yo game stuff oh
that was a dope one that was better yep
yeah I remember I had a bunch of teepee
and I wanted to flex on all the [ __ ]
haters out there
hmm interesting I guess a young TP guys
what do you think
Andrew take eat your heart out dude this
is what real talent looks like [ __ ]
happy Monday [ __ ] suck on my ass [ __ ]
[ __ ] in my dick [ __ ] anyway so here's
the next one called part time
uh that's in reference to
um how much his dad was in his life
foreign
there's a reason he is the way he is
just saying
just saying
can you crank it a little bit
I don't like him
get this guy out of all your videos bro
he he's carrying all this [ __ ] and he
just sings for like 75 of it I had it
time stamped at Tate's part dude he
doesn't start till that deep yeah bro
nobody cares about this guy he sucks
okay here now that's what I'm here for
Parts
[Music]
[Music]
this is a touching romantic I don't call
you but I miss you a lot mom
foreign
I love you Mommy
yo bars for days
[Music]
he's like so hard he's like bro I'm not
gonna curse in my song I'm not this is
the clean version
I'm a human traffic people but I'm gonna
do a clean version keep it respectful
yeah I won't say that b word
[Music]
oh I love you Mom
I love you Grandma
but you leave me I love you mommy please
come back
yo I'm not watching this dude I refuse
to watch this [ __ ] guy sing
not happening
nope
[Music]
he goes
I was holding your hand you said it was
big
I said I know baby
[Music]
dude you want to see how Goofy and
this guy actually looks there's a couple
moments where he actually shows his face
like look at this
dude dude I'm telling you
yes and I don't listen it's not nice to
make fun of a people's appearance but
he's a human trafficker
right
right
that's just what I'm saying man it's got
kind of a freakish head he looks like a
llama
looks like a seal
just saying
just saying
what what is this
is that it's Tristan that's his brother
why did he put like the baby filter on
his face
that's what elfas do
who better to be with on Save ashes
than my drunken Irish henchmen
here he is now
he's got a gun and a
uh Aston Martin
awesome bro
sick
[Music]
nope I'm not listening to your [ __ ]
friend bro
no shot
[Music]
that's what I'm saying bro you got to do
better than that he leans on his singing
dude way too much
so um part-time what do we think
he's talking about how how frequently I
was paid he looks like a turtle they're
right yeah I was just saying that too
he's [ __ ] Turtle tape
Turtle tape the human trafficker
you made the comparison to Dana Carvey
and the master of disguise right I'm not
Turtle enough for the turtle club
Okay Turtle take guys let's do it
Beetlejuice head you're right I didn't
want to say it but that's what I mean he
looks like maybe his his mom smoked
crack when she was pregnant with him
you know
all right having fun here guys there's
one more called forgot your name
it's actually about his biological
mother
[Music]
[ __ ] your mom how about that
very sad oh there's virgin day and
turtle Tate
yes Cameron
I think Ian's actually doing that
wait what turtle is that from what movie
is that
Kung Fu Panda
what'd you say Kung Fu Panda oh Kung Fu
Panda yeah and that's a turtle Ian
original by the way oh good Ian you did
that while switching that's right that's
why it's way worse what an in Talent
what an incredible Talent we have here
you guys are all talented man
because they're all incredible
all right we forgot your name
[Music]
what's your name baby
bring a turtleneck
what is happening right now that's the
official music video no no this is the
record release party it gets into the
video
uh just get forward a little bit this
one only got 70 000 views Tate that's
kind of cringe
[Music]
not this guy oh God come on
hell no bro I never knew your name and I
don't want to know it you're out
this is who I'm here to see the
Superstar
[Music]
dude has a hot tub in his front yard
if that's not luxury I don't know what
is [ __ ] who has a hot tub in
their front yard
that's weird
Turtle ass looking [ __ ]
what's your name baby you need to come
near the club's a little loud so it's
hard to hear or drink I'll have a beer
that is
[Music]
bars
well let's make it fast I'm buying
champagne till I seen that ass
that's true
oh God that's facts all facts no printer
I need to know your name but it's all
the same too many years on them played
in this [ __ ] game I had a lot of love
way before the fame out of field drained
everything yo yeah oh type go to your
YouTube and type money falling green
screen
guaranteed they just rip this off
YouTube royalty free [ __ ]
every day I'll Make It Rain baby baby
give me the first to last we got the ice
breaking maybe you should grab a glass
and gotta do the small talk yep there it
is
first result
dollar money falling free background
animation Loop footage green screen
Motion Graphics VFX
shout out Cobra Tate
[Applause]
hmm
[Music]
but I'm sorry baby I forgot your name I
forgot your name nope
dude not doing it bro imagine making a
video with this these lyrics and using
green screen money it's amazing I
thought he would spend a little money on
the production yeah but he literally
just has a hot tub in his front yard
and green screen money
[Music]
that sure sounded like it let me get
another just read on that
sorry baby I forgot your name
stop is it Becky is it Amy baby I forgot
you distracted me looking too hot why
you dancing you just wrapped to me
looking too hot
well then it's informed me my dick is
hard
the police are here
[Music]
the police are here they want to know
about the girls that I have locked in my
basement for sure
I paid them off then they went away
baby I forgot your name the girl in the
basement what's your name again I forgot
your name
hmm
the girl walked to the oven I forgot
your name his name is Ethan Klein
foreign
God the [ __ ] why do you wish that
every line doesn't need to rhyme like
you don't need to use the Mother Goose
[ __ ] rhyme scheme for every single
[ __ ] line ABAB yeah it's like why
does she wish they had a credit card and
a couple kids dude I can just imagine
him sitting up at night you know [ __ ]
probably fueled on cocaine and just
rhyme with a rhyming dictionary a
thesaurus yeah just all night like [ __ ]
yeah bro
[Laughter]
this is fire dude
and I call you baby we can have sex a
bunch you can call me Brady we can have
sex a bunch what are you 12.
[Music]
not you bro I'm not listening to you
have sex a bunch you can call me Brady
yeah what is it like The Brady Bunch
okay a bunch of kids okay sex
sex
I wonder what Jordan Peterson whose
daughter's best friends with him thinks
about this well there you have it Andrew
Tate guys Turtle Tate the human
trafficker
coasting his own elves ladies and
gentlemen he's got it he's got a future
in the rap game yo we can have sex a
whole bunch
okay
I'm gonna whip this hole
okay
yo Andrew they check this [ __ ] out I've
had sex and I didn't even have to rape
them
okay let's go damn next up hey Andrew
check it out I'm married and I love my
wife owned
[ __ ] wrecked bars yeah but you sleep
in a race car
nope hey Andrew I sleep in a big bed
with my wife
owned next
[Music]
let's go hey Andrew the embassies never
visited my house wondering if I have sex
slaves in my basement
owned King Kong next hey Andrew guess
what I've got hair owned
next home next let's go owned next hey
Andrew guess what
I have kids that love me
owned next
I have a bunch of sex owned
a ton a bunch of sex
[Laughter]
yeah yeah yo Andrew guess what I got a
hot tub in my backyard
oh man
next on next I got a hot tub that has
privacy in my own backyard [ __ ] next
I live hey Andrew guess what I live in
America where there's actually laws and
you're and you can't pay off uh being a
human trafficker next
hey guess what Andrew I'm not on uh uh
interpol's most wanted list next
yes
okay Andrew Cobra takes that your name
maybe you should have
uh gotten gene therapy when you were a
kid because your mom smoked crack next
oh there there he
look like a turtle
Okay Turtle Boy Next
let's go
it's not your fault it's not your fault
code Bridge not your fault it's not your
fault Cobra it's not your fault
don't cry baby it's not your fault Cobra
all this stuff here it's not your fault
Goodwill Hunting next
I need somebody to jump in with the hook
and like repeat it like 10 times you
drinking your bubble water go ahead
you're drinking your bubble water you
got [ __ ]
[Music]
hey oh you cook wow what a [ __ ] I just
eat five dollar Costco chickens next
only [ __ ] cooked next bubble water
I'm a human trafficker Cobra Tate a
human traffic on my babes make money
selling all the babes and to Paula wants
me anyway
next bubble water you'll be drinking
bubble water
[Music]
hey two cigars a day
okay
anything else
pretty fired beats though absolutely
[Music]
bubble what who cooks who cooks who
cooks
you don't want to be a bait Ass [ __ ]
don't be a beta being a beta is death
but reality Andrew
[Music]
hey Andrew guess what I know who my mom
is next next
[Music]
my mom's name's Donna and I see her
almost every weekend
got him because she drink the bubble
water
yo my mom wasn't drinking bubble water
one week and I slapped her in the face
and called her a [ __ ]
[ __ ] baby now
[ __ ] baby [ __ ] it's Friday [ __ ] baby
[ __ ]
[Music]
oh damn we gotta put my mom on the mic
dooba bit do brick
human trafficking in the basement human
trafficking in the basement
oh all right that's enough without it
it's pretty fun though eh Good Times
yo someone says currently twerking on my
bong okay let's go
um I realized none of those music videos
that we watched was the one that he hit
wait that none of those were the uh no
here here's the link to the uh
to the now good privated one Tate is
crying and [ __ ] right now let me see
if it's still private at it
oh wait so we never actually watched the
private one
there's got to be a re-upload somewhere
now here it is it's still private yeah
there is
um here there's the link
okay oh oh [ __ ]
it's called s word I'm alive
putting that in the title probably not a
good idea and alive I you know I didn't
even want to say it yeah because it's
just such a bad word for the sensor
but let's watch it I guess
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
and then he says Kurt Cobain like bro
shut up [ __ ] you I mean I made a Kurt
Cobain suicide joke earlier today yeah
but like that was a quality joke yeah
there's another popular rap song that
says that I just can't think what it is
hey the way he did it is not good
suicide bro he didn't have he can't even
say Kurt Cobain you're not cool enough
bro Dan you're cool enough
Kurt Cobain McLaren 720 but it sound
like a plane when I'm on the road stay
in your lane beat getting killed like a
shot to the brain suicide suicide
suicide okay okay
[Music]
[Music]
did it dirty no soap
so weird flex but okay yeah
I don't think you need to be rich to get
soap bud
you know what's a bar sub cost
49 cents [ __ ]
Irish Springs cause I'm rich
Bubba what and I was spring Dove soap
big bubbles from my bubble soup
write a suicide note but now I kill a
[ __ ] suicide notes
[Music]
[Applause]
to the game I don't want to hang about
white chicks No Doubt Me White Chicks
no doubt are you like Gwen Stefani no
doubt dude what exactly are you implying
he's just a girl like Gwen Stefani no
doubt
what does he say he does better than any
line in his song is he saying he doesn't
[ __ ] anything but white chicks
that's not he says white chicks No Doubt
I mean
I don't think he's really thought too
deeply about any of these lyrics I think
yeah he's mixed I knew I found he's down
yeah I think he's probably saying like
white chicks what's up it's like no
doubt I'll kiss you he's no doubt his
dad was like a world-renowned chess
player
oh that's interesting right I know yeah
I I learned a lot about his dad was
absent and I think uh I read that I
don't know where but I'm pretty sure
that's true
and I think that's a lot of the
insecurities came from he was talking
about his debt his dad was like a crazy
chauvinist womanizer too
similar vibes
I mean I think it's psychological if you
get down to it I think a lot of this is
just looking for Daddy's approval
hmm
when he says white chicks do you think
that he would make out with uh the Wayne
brothers in Whiteface
is that what he's talking about maybe
yup
that's what I think too
but now I'm gonna make a suicide notes
bang it out bang it out
kind of money made these hoes wanna
shout so Bounce With Me Bounce With Me
got my brothers
[Music]
[ __ ] hands in the sky for me
[Music]
when I'm
gonna stay in your lane be getting
killed like a shot to the brain suicide
suicide
[Music]
up
he got his short verse still send sales
money
I might buy a boat all right y'all
I'm too hot oh my God
he should name his yacht daddy issues
yeah I'm over it too guys
uh
there you have it
Cobra thumb
Andrew is top G invite him on
if you think otherwise and watch you be
afraid of getting canceled like he will
humble you just like xqc when did xqc
humble me now take this 10 I earned off
Andrew's website thanks for the 10. bro
he donated even more he had to for me to
read it like you could have just given
five yeah is he saying Tate humbled xqc
oh is that like oh he's saying I'm about
to xqc I don't think he did but see so I
was saying people were disagreeing
people were agreeing with love when I
said I don't think xqc should have them
on and then people say well that's what
you're doing
maybe I didn't think about it that way
my thinking was like having uh Cobra the
human trafficker on your show
gives him the opportunity to basically
lie and manipulate and spin [ __ ]
and then it's all like clips and fodder
for his whole media apparatus
like I've been saying clips of him like
owning xqc whatever
well because they have I mean he
literally runs a Ponzi scheme where dumb
[ __ ] like pie whatever the hell pie is
pay money to
promote him I mean that apparently
that's part of the program like his way
of teaching you to make money is go post
a bunch of clips about me
I like that system anyone out there want
to do that I'm down but it's literally a
Ponzi because they get an affiliate code
and then they try and recruit people to
it and they get a cut it's quite
literally a multi-level marketing scheme
yes so congratulations of getting
suckered into a Ponzi scheme and pain no
it's funny bro it's some [ __ ] weirdo
hey you know what's funny pies King I'm
gonna make more money than you do and I
you just gave me 10 bucks and I'm gonna
make ten dollars more than you ever do
on this [ __ ]
so thanks idiot
I mean he's almost certainly lost money
at this point especially he's just
giving it away in order to uh donate on
random channels so but good luck with
that Pike King I I get it you know
between like having him on or not I
personally don't think
talking about them like we are here is
the same as having them on because it
deprives some of the ability to
twist [ __ ] and [ __ ] make his little
own compilation or whatever and
yeah um I agree but you know it is it is
good on the other hand like love was
saying that you know it's it is it's
good that xqc and Dave porkboy are
saying whatever but I don't know it's
hard with him because he really is just
such a sick [ __ ]
yeah
I think the best way is to just
humiliate them and treat them like
debate as they are you know he's not a
serious dude he's a [ __ ] beta
criminal insecure I mean the guys has
daddy issues straight up
love didn't he just get upset and just
hang up the call with xqc yeah he
thought the xqc was annoying and I left
yeah
that's an L that's massive yeah
never be a beta
uh Sierra said and this is so true you
know he says you're ugly anyway when a
girl rejects him so true yep
so true
but okay whatever you know somebody just
beats them within an inch of their life
because he does not do but you know I'm
just gonna say
um
it's hard to know what's better or
what's worse that's just my opinion I
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna hate on xqc
or pork boy I shouldn't hate on them too
much for having them on
uh but you know
here's 50 of my hard-earned cash keep it
up thank you
I thought this was going to be another
Tate shout out
and guess what for fifty dollars you
don't have to do anything for us you
don't have to post Clips
back it up oh you good so my Dub's on
Tick Tock oh you're kind of into it yes
okay all right it's you speaking it okay
I apologize for donating 50 you are now
actually legally obligated yeah to post
at least five Clips to social media
about the history project yes yes that's
what we need 50 videos as long as you
donate the proceeds of course to me to
us right yeah exactly right it all comes
back around all leads all all for all
things are possible With God all roads
lead back to Ethan oh thank you with God
nerd tendo good luck with covid buddy
keep it up proud of you
top well there it is Cobra taint
the human trafficker folks
we're fighting back
this is what an alpha looks like you may
not like it
okay this is Peak male Alpha right here
and it's time to just accept that this
is what it looks like
maximum donating five dollars here's
five dollars per being a hairline
Kingdom and get laid without paying for
it thanks Max and look at this I'll be
expecting the post within 24 hours
look at this [ __ ] cobra
cry owned next owned next owned next
let's get it
oh Kyla said she met Cobra at a party
but he wouldn't give her any champagne
because she wouldn't show him his ass
yeah well he's upfront about that yeah
so that's true yeah
that's true
speaking of womanizing freaks uh Vitale
TV you guys may remember
we've talked about it he was one of the
Original Pranksters on YouTube I have
big balls he's a Russian
dude who lives here I don't know how
he's still here
he's on a Visa probably a special person
Visa at this point I think he came as a
student or something
I'm not sure exactly but he did talk
about almost losing it after the
incident that happened in Miami yeah he
was tripping balls recently on some drug
and he just started attacking a random
passer buyer he beat the crap out of her
and he uh I guess they had they settled
something and she dropped the charges
yeah he was on Roman Atwood's podcast
and he mentioned that there was a
settlement or some kind of arrangement
but he couldn't go into detail oh here
it is yeah um but he's back on YouTube
with some crazy ass [ __ ] spoke Roman
Atwood
I don't know how the [ __ ] you can pay
someone to not get deported after you've
done something like that
I just well I think you'd only get
deported if you were convicted of a
crime and how can the charges were
dropped then
I mean it makes sense to me yeah if you
can pay someone not to I mean if you set
a lot of court or well it depends on the
state but I believe California is a
state like that some if if you're like
assaulted you have to press charges
can't the D.A choose to profit you
regardless I'm not an expert but I I
seem to recall hearing about this just
recently because of the Will Smith slap
incident because Chris Rock didn't press
charges and people were like well they
should just charge them anyways it
happened on TV and they couldn't because
if Chris Rock wasn't pressing charges
they couldn't do anything about it
legal experts in the chat that know
otherwise but yeah I mean this incident
happened in Florida and so whatever
Florida law is of Florida is a small
game whatever yeah probably
uh but here is uh this is my next
question is have you spoke to this one
spoke to her till this day wow that's
how I tried to let her apology letter
like obviously she shouldn't forgive me
but uh how sorry I'm that's not me I had
no I don't I didn't know her I didn't
know what I did you were a demon yeah
but demons the thing came out of me bro
I didn't know yeah I mean what could
have been a guy it could have been
anybody it's not just that was big oh
let me find a helpless girl and do this
to her I didn't know what I was doing at
a time yeah so I wrote her tried to
learn her apology letter and to reach
out to my lawyer I didn't know her name
nothing like I was gonna give dude I was
ready to give her a whole world bro I
just felt I Still Still his day I just
feel terrible that I'm even spoke and
you know
I mean it is it's the law you can't so
you haven't spoke to you don't even know
if she's read the letter
she read the list she read the letter
though just through lawyers through
lawyers is this a current situation
that's still acting I'm still not
allowed to talk about what how it ended
but okay my charges got dismissed oh
they have yeah I'm not a felon anymore
it's over yeah oh it's been over I did
not know oh wow yeah uh yeah it's been
over my charges got dismissed I was
getting deported but yeah nice to be
rich eh [ __ ] rules that money
okay so the felony charges have dropped
dismissed like as in she dropped them or
actually saying that Florida is not like
this game
[Music]
he says they came to an agreement
although the victim May initially be the
one to involve the police once the State
of Florida has decided to file charges
against someone the case is out of the
victim's hands
so no actually it sounds like he could
have still been charged even if the
victim
the main point here is that
you can see how sorry he is and you know
he's changed yeah
that's horrible of an incident as it was
he's uh grown from it
anyway here's his new video
from this month July 13th
back with a banger
epic farting on girls prank
July 13th
the king of Franks himself wow I love
how here is it I feel like we've gone
back in time here this is July 13 2022
my friend this is fresh [ __ ] when it
comes to pranks I'm a badass I love how
it's specifically farting on girls yeah
tough guy he's like I've learned my
lesson man I'm a reformed man here I'm
farting on girls on the beach watch this
[ __ ] today eight minutes all right
[ __ ] back every Wednesday this is
farting on girl spring and every
Wednesday has he uploaded since then let
me check right he posted a video last
week yeah he posted a video until this
week 11 days ago like kind of like an
apology video that that truth about my
downfall yeah
um it was just like him apologizing but
um he's reformed bro yeah
oh well he's gonna post a new video in
two days that should be exciting
let's get it
how far it is
why [ __ ] away why
or what's gonna happen leave us alone
you forgot to screw right
yeah leave us the [ __ ] alone you [ __ ]
creep can't hear you why are you here
Lee I can't hear you what the [ __ ]
dude are you the new man got him dude
holy [ __ ] I've never seen someone get
pranked that hard dude dude I love her
and this is like the good old just a
prank [ __ ] he's bringing it back yo you
gotta love how he like goes farce on
them like a total free creep loser these
girls might know him because he's like
oh you forgot to scream rape you [ __ ]
woke liberal losers
Jesus oh God what did you expect bro
this guy is a [ __ ] walking trap he's
changed yeah I love that I'm so sorry
guys man I wanted to give her my whole
world anyway uh epic farting on girls
prank
excuse me I'm sorry it's a bother you I
have a question is that a hole in my
pants look here
what the [ __ ] I'm sorry what the [ __ ]
you got the [ __ ] yeah no bro you got to
get there this one seems fake I mean
they might all be fair I mean yeah the
camera placement on this one is the
other one felt real her reaction this
one feels fake as a [ __ ] but what's more
insane if it's real if it's not real
that first one that's that's the real
question
yeah that he felt like it was okay to
post that
dude yeah
please no
but you got the shits or something oh
this is the fakest interaction ever
click you don't [ __ ] we all [ __ ] but not
right now it's just a party machine
it's so epic wow you're good
why what's up why would you come in
coming up I just sharted I didn't fart
why would you do that oh it's leaking
down my leg I'm sorry
I liked you guys that's my pickup line
let's not do that really
no oh I'm in a new one breaking news oh
[ __ ] toxic
Ethan Klein Teddy Frick's allegations
wait oh the toxic workplace allegations
yeah wait I gotta see how we covered
this
Phil would be like what do you guys
think are these real reviews or not what
do you guys think is Ethan a piece of
[ __ ] I'm gonna pass off the question to
you guys let me know is Ethan a criminal
I'm gonna pass it off for you guys in
the comments I gotta see what the [ __ ]
Phil you better have been good with this
[ __ ] or I'm gonna be pissed I don't want
none of that fence sitting on this
there's like a hundred Glass Door
reviews now on Teddy fresh
or like a 50 I don't know how many are
in there it's funny I believe it's
around 50 yeah 46. yeah it's so
ridiculous
I read on a glass Philip DeFranco be
like if one of the reviews said people
are locked to the uh their desks and
forced to work 26 hours a day what do
you guys think
leave your comments below
someone pulling it up
Oh I thought you had it I'm sorry I
wouldn't have it I got it I heard it I
thought I was coming from you
or do you have a timestamp though
wait why is Phil in a hotel room welcome
back to the Philip DeFranco show to
anyone that doubted you were gonna get a
show just because I was on the road how
dare you a healthy work-life balance in
this economy Monday to Thursday
sometimes even Fridays expect to see my
dumb face spewing nonsense I bet you
just relax sit back hit that like button
and let's just jump you want me to hit
the like jump into it yeah Phil give
them a like I didn't even watch the
video yet you can't mom I am asking for
the lights
that's a like fraud no no no no no no
that's not you can't be prosecuted for
that not in California how do I know if
it's a good video or not because you're
in the thumb and he made it exactly well
I gotta see what he says about me first
tell me what you think in the comments
been doing the first thing that we're
going to talk about today is this
controversy with Teddy fresh Ethan Klein
and Ela Klein because in addition to the
hugely popular H3 podcast I like that he
said huge really popular
I like that a lot yeah the Omega
successful Teddy forever Mega successful
Teddy fresh I like that
keep going Philly you can get your like
out of me keep it up Phil or show my
screen
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
listen I'm just giving him the benefit
of the doubt I can I can switch it to a
dislike at any point okay and remember
that Phil I like it
all right remember your finger on the
butt I like it I'm gonna keep my finger
on that bun
it was because they addressed
accusations that their clothing brand is
a toxic place to work at where a lot of
that seeming to stem from Glass Door
reviews where the company has a 1.8 star
rating some of the negative reviews
they're calling it a sinking ship saying
that it's abusive and extremely toxic
and that the bosses treat employees like
garbage some are from as recently as
this month others as far back as around
December of 2021 and on their podcast
Ethan and Ela said that these were bad
faith reviews likely written by people
who never even worked at Teddy fresh but
even saying just the timing all of this
feels like a red flag Teddy fresh has
been in
business for five long years and all
these reviews started springing up six
months ago five years nothing there and
then all of a sudden six months ago
there's like all at once like 15 [ __ ]
negative reviews and eventually had Ela
saying you know some of these could be
legitimate which is something she
obviously finds concerning but that she
believes that the majority are just
unjustified attacks with this saying she
really tries to make sure that this is a
good place to work I don't know I mean
like maybe maybe there's a couple that
are real there and it obviously it
really is sad to see and it I mean I'm I
I take it very seriously and
I do believe that we're improving the
company all the time and constantly
working on it okay hold on Phil this is
your fault bro the second ties comment
is Ethan needs to take a break he's
literally in a different Scandal each
week of course I am I'm at Billy G push
me in every video
that's Philly D's fault
not mine
just Billy D puts me in a scandal every
week
just reporting this it just means
irrelevant that's it let the
conversation begin it's a good thing
okay this is a night I've never watched
or listened to H3 not my cup of tea but
my God the amount of [ __ ] Ethan elit uh
actually have to deal with that your
report is insane Bish best wishes them
okay thank you I love the running joke
of Ethan and title thumbnail
okay okay all right all right let's keep
watching
I'm not taking a break I'm fine
Mercedes Perez
[Music]
pumped up on [ __ ] antidepressants I'm
fine
bully gained 70 pounds in the last year
[Laughter]
don't sleep
don't worry
I'm like trying to make sure
it's a really good environment for our
employees we try to make everyone feel
like they're they're valued because we
really do value everybody that works for
us I don't think it's toxic
I mean they'll be like well what do you
think
I I'm there like all the time I I get
along great with everybody I feel like
we all collaborate it's like it's a fun
place to work at and adding like Ethan
noted the timing of all this feels weird
but Ethan then also going on to say that
he would concede that one or two of
these negative reviews are real but also
saying how would they know since
Glassdoor doesn't actually ask the
company to verify who is writing these
reviews and then adding but the thing is
when you're working in a job for five
years people come and go and every
breakup isn't always amicable and some
people I'll be honest some people are
employees and they suck and you need to
fire them that's just reality of owning
a business but still coming back and
saying that yeah you know what I'm
talking about right AB yeah just kidding
you're a great employee I was just
trying to make a joke no you are you are
a great employee I'm so glad and
grateful you're here don't forget about
the meeting we have scheduled to help
all the channels tea channels get all
this I want to see my face
here's a sad face for the thumbnail
yeah I'll look angry actually was there
anything you wanted to say to the
Audience by the way for any reason
um
nah
I'll save it for it well there might be
there might not be another one I have a
few people I could talk to if anything
they can even put horns on my head Jew
horns
laughs
majority of these reviews are [ __ ]
it's just so [ __ ] up and it's so
obvious to me
that it's all bad faith like we work so
hard specifically Ila to build this
company and do it the right way
and I feel like there's really nothing
bad you can say or criticize Teddy fresh
for like my myself and this show there's
plenty of shock and uh criticize me for
you can make a billion yeah but Teddy
fresh is not like that it's like clean
and wholesome further claiming that they
try to do right by their employees by
giving generous pay benefits perks
Severance packages and more I'm saying
these reviews just do not pay an
accurate picture of what is going on at
Teddy fresh noting that this kind of
stuff always seems to happen when
something big is going on right now they
have this big big sale and saying these
takedowns are just time to line up with
something like that and also as far as
who is responsible they say you know
this obviously stems from those Glass
Door reviews but also it started getting
traction on Reddit and getting tons of
attention with Ethan saying and my what
my theory is is that
this is being fueled by
Trisha by the way I saw people going
crazy about my risk my wrist came too on
Reddit like how does his hand stay on
his arm
yeah that one's kind of annoying
keemstar and possibly Cav cab and then
later regarding Trisha Paytas
specifically he seemed to try to make a
separating point between Trisha and her
fans there's a community of like Trisha
stands who ate my guts and this Glass
Door reviews are always posted there not
talking about her no it's not about it
okay yeah just say that I'll say
nutrition has nothing to do with it but
there's a community of psychos that has
nothing to do with her she doesn't
interact with them it's not her fault
I'm just saying that it's always posted
there and people there are participating
in the same thing so it just became like
a
for people to be like I worked at Teddy
fresh and they're treated us like Lord
of the Flies as far as the responses
here it is worth noting in the past
couple of days since addressing the
whole situation the teddy fresh glass
door has been filled with positive
five-star reviews and notably there's
some clearly coming from fans who are
joking about whether or not they
actually work there as far as my opinion
yeah based off of the timing it feels
like very much like review bombing
unfortunately across many businesses has
become this standard thing I mean in
some places that it's even used as
blackmail as well as the fact if you run
any business eventually you're going to
have people that are disgruntled
ex-employees well of course with this
story yes I'm passing the question off
to you I just I personally I can't
imagine Ela Klein running a bad or toxic
company like you're talking about the
woman that's able to successfully parent
and manage Ethan
[ __ ] god
warming is continuing to take its toll
worldwide with Europe bro wow
[Applause]
you know what Franco you earned that
thumbs up for me that's beautiful I
can't believe you doubted you know what
I just I didn't want to do it for like
fraud can we call it thumbs up
thumbs up
that's good wow everybody like Billy
give a shout out to Sexy Phil sexy fan
skinny Legend Philip DeFranco what a
legend [ __ ] baby Julius top G he is
he's top G he is one he's one of the
best guys ever he's top dude depending
on how he reported that he's my favorite
guy ever give it a thumbs up
also shout out Philly I've been making
major gains on the thumbnails lately
yeah so that's awesome I need to
reassess soon
no I love Philly he's my favorite guy
he's one of the best guys that ever
lived probably
I sub I stand I like
well why he put us on here I don't like
that
yeah I'll be honest he's got a chill on
the Hassan ones spread the love a little
bit love I said the the Hassan clip
didn't get too many views oh yeah see
let's lose the numbers proof is in the
pudding bro Hassan just don't pull the
views like I do LL
uh I love you buddy you're the best that
ever did it by the way just because I
saw some people asking
um about uh leftovers we're we're back
this week oh [ __ ] I didn't even realize
I love that God we have so much to talk
about so much it's my I've just been
periodically throwing things nice
just been periodically throwing stuff in
the leftovers dock in preparation for
this week and I looked at it this
morning and it's
there's like five episodes worth of [ __ ]
yeah right now we usually get through
like one thing right
um so welcome back fatality can't wait
for your new video uh in two days
yep
called pretending to jizz on women in
public Sports them with a bottle and it
says it was his jizz didn't sees how
they react
he's he's reformed stupid [ __ ] Karen
overreacts
[ __ ] yeah would you even scream rape
that's disgusting
God
um did you guys know Vitale was on an
episode of Bangbus
so he's doing um no you didn't no I
swear to God he was years ago before he
was famous on YouTube he was on an
episode of Bangbus and he would he
couldn't get it up oh wait I didn't know
this story him and his homie got called
into the bank bus yeah and he couldn't
his dick was out and it was soft the
whole time and he was just sadly in the
background with the soft dick while his
buddy [ __ ] the girl keep the whole
video he's just sitting there soft he's
doing uh of now
oh for real yeah like what kind of stuff
is he making well I I was just looking
at his Instagram and it looks like he's
working with an adult film star so so
he's actually
performing I it's what it looks like it
could just be a troll but um I don't
think there's
I don't know if he could get it up you
know
dude that's so funny bro
yeah but now that that Bangbus thing is
real man it's kind of gnarly it's
awesome
oh here we got a preview of reach lux's
new video
Ethan the evil Jew horns firing for a b
bad boy a b bad boy bad boy bad boy yeah
you can use this uh reach Lux if you
want to can I use it yeah you can use it
I might use something unrelated you
should use it before him I'd rather you
get the clout than him okay actually let
me put on my crater Clash video I'll
just use this without contact that is
good let's go
you're a bad boy
um actually I want speaking of the glass
door controversy
there were some really funny ones that
came up that I wanted to point out just
to show you how uh Vigilant the
moderation is on that website
great place to work I definitely worked
here Pros
best part was definitely 100 working
there cons worst part was Ethan
constantly pooping in the bathroom
advice try Activia five stars thank you
good sir for that uh how it might be
real
very real based off the cons
they do seem to have some inside
information that's true it's kind of
hard yeah how was would they know that
right if they didn't work there
five stars Teddy fresh is literally a
sweatshop
pros and they like it yeah that's what
five star rating start raining
Pros pretty cool shirts I like Looney
Tunes workers get 10 off the merch when
they use code Rudy at checkout
[Music]
cons I put my heart and soul into
creating the iconic color block hoodie
when I presented it to Eli she punched
me in the face spat on me and stole my
design they also charge for the
disgusting filtered water
or at least provide natural spring water
please workers can't afford to stay
hydrated with how little we are paid and
many die from heat stroke advice to
management you better get a good lawyer
because I will be seeking legal action
well thanks for the five star it's a
little confusing yeah get the [ __ ]
maybe you got confused on this rating
system
two stars toxic toxicity
Pros free merch Pros Dollar in the woods
the woods found a dead dog
dollars toxic uh uh Lord of the Flies or
something advice to management there's
no way a website would let you leave
obviously fake reviews right all these
reviews are real and definitely not come
star Fanboys the employees were a little
old for my taste not once
well thank you well thank you King for
this one
hit me with that again
that's hysterical
deep that man is on the verge holy [ __ ]
you know it's funny when you first leave
a review on Glassdoor I saw this on the
subreddit somebody posted the before and
after uh
and it shows like waiting on for 24
hours for to be approved by the
moderators right that's just they give
you this illusion that there's somebody
there checking it to prevent people try
to keep leaving fake reviews
um there's no moderation obviously look
at these reviews
foreign
people almost too many pizza parties and
tons of bathroom breaks
and also the con is too much confusion
between Cav cab and Weinstein which I
totally get that yep
advice to management always do the right
thing
16 people found this review helpful
so nice shout out
Grace is with the future Pros extreme
different very humble amazing fun to
work cons the heat of La is not good
this was the one that uh my favorite
that was held for review for 24 hours
and approved yeah High thrust pleasure
to finally meet you that's deep Cav Lord
that's what he wrote on the Shrek for it
Pros you've been a very busy boy maybe
we should talk sooner or later that's
what Kafka wrote on the Shrek Forum it's
such a great copy pasta
cons this is a legitimate review and it
did not take me five minutes to sign up
and leave a review it is impossible for
trolls to review bomb class class store
trust me guys their system is as
foolproof as Ryan Kavanaugh's Wikipedia
advice to management what do we do about
it
that's what he wrote to me on LinkedIn
too
he wrote nice to finally meet oh that's
what loves yeah
and then you responded he never answered
right yeah he said nice to finally meet
you perhaps we should talk and I said
hey what's up Ryan how can I help you
and he just never responded yeah what a
coward what a [ __ ] or he did and you
guys have a secret Arrangement oh oh
he's the mole he's the one that's the
ball you're the one that leaked that I
[ __ ] I have nasty shits in the bathroom
aren't you love what do I wish I could
show you guys right here did you leak
the
the Denny's incident too did you lick
the Denny's thing love be honest no what
the heck this is all we we said it's
like completely blown out except for
Ryan Cavanaugh's stupid little [ __ ]
face
what do we do about it
[Music]
I had unprotected anal with my wife
that's why I'm wearing this helmet
so um
oh yeah keemstar dude this guy is so out
of control he's so upset that this [ __ ]
is like backfiring on him look at this
he tweeted this out
after our after our podcast uh first
talking about it last week
Teddy fresh is getting exposed for
treating employees bad allegedly
thanks for throwing that in
so h33 fans are in a group chat on
Discord trying to feed me false info all
acting like their former employees to
cause confusion so real employees don't
have a voice
h3hd fans are pathetic
uh this isn't
oh
yeah I mean it's like a hobby to [ __ ]
with you Kim
um but
my favorite part
is this person says how do you know
these messages are Bad actors and he
responds because we have a full list of
their employees of all their employees
dude you are so sad and pathetic imagine
even admitting to that is so
embarrassing it's like obsessive and
like pathological
is that not [ __ ] disturbing and like
crazy I mean and like it's I guess it's
Paul I mean listen
whether it's true or not
I I don't I don't take it seriously
even just saying that is so [ __ ]
embarrassing dude
it's straight giving me Ethan folder
Vibes yeah
yo Saudi Prince just dropped 50. oh
what's up player by the name uh 50
legally obtained reviews oh my boy
Prince uh MBS what's his name
uh uh MBL
no it is
MBS my boy we love you
Mecca
shout out Mecca
let's see Saudi Arabia right it is but I
mean it's about the [ __ ] out Mecca it's
a place not a person I love that [ __ ]
over there yeah okay
that's like that's like the coolest
place in Saudi Arabia right
it's where the holiest location
it's a major Flex yeah yeah it's a major
Flex that's a banger spot bro they have
Mecca
right shut the [ __ ] out Mecca dude okay
I think it makes sense when I go there
I'm gonna wear a shirt that says shut up
Mecca
had to go once baby
One Time's enough because you're
supposed to go there once yeah yes once
in your life so wait are you supposed to
make a pilgrimage in your life oh what's
up player shut the [ __ ] out Mecca dude
that's awesome when you are you do you
know when you want to go yeah probably
one of a better Muslim oh yeah right of
course maybe down the line you're gonna
nail the uh the devil you know isn't
that one of the things you do on uh the
pilgrimage uh not that I know but again
I don't have the instructions so
possibly I mean Dan you know more about
Islam than me sometimes
I believe one of the things is you throw
rocks at uh something and it's supposed
to be your like stoning the devil
basically which is kind of metal yeah
that's being honest yo Mecca is The
Vibes there are pretty immaculate
like you have to cruise around in socks
or Barefoot and they keep it so clean
look at this Legend yeah Hezbollah I
love it
they keep it super clean and everyone's
Barefoot do you know what's the lore
though with this like pillar
uh Lena
cowboy
and inside there is a stone that
supposedly uh
what's the religious significance of it
yeah it's related to The Prophet's
family let me see
I missed the question what's the
significance of Gaba
and Mecca
well let me look it up really quickly I
don't want to mess this up people will
be really upset
yeah I know I was trying to pass it off
something dope is in there oh oh yeah
something [ __ ] insane is in there
actually we can't tell you yeah I get it
and this is a door can you go inside
there no you can't no it represents the
metaphorical House of God so nobody goes
in nobody goes out
no you just go around it and pray
well at some point people go in but like
not the public like I think just you
know clerics and stuff are allowed in
there but what's in there dude
I still
[ __ ] uh I'm not I say I can't joke I
I I take your guys's Faith seriously and
I respect it I think Mecca's sick though
looks [ __ ] fire there
lean are you gonna go you want to go to
Mecca during your life Avery said yes
yeah for sure sometime in my life that's
awesome yeah Prophet Ibrahim and his son
uh Prophet Ishmael constructed the kava
following the command of God as stated
in the Quran but what's in the what's in
the I'm not sure what's it let's Google
it someone Google it what's inside that
[ __ ]
I mean no it's a beautiful it's a
beautiful place
speaking colloquially oh this person
saying Abraham and his son built it
but aren't those Jews Jews Abraham we
have yeah we have somewhere it's the
same yeah it's the same tradition so how
come Jews don't care about it
well oh this is the inside pick yo
inside assistant actually yo
so is this the holy thing here
and I was right there it's called the
black stone of Mecca is the the stone
that I was referencing this is it on
sorcerer's son that's what that's what
that's the Islamic term for it we call
it the Sorcerer's Stone yo so what's the
significant of it it's just Abraham and
his son built it yeah it's supposed to
be a a place where you meet with all
Muslims and uh
pray together I mean and even more
specifically there's one of the five
pillars of Islam
but what's the there was going to be
significant of the item okay whatever
those things you just you just know it's
just one of those things it's just one
of those things what the [ __ ] it's it's
a Vibe it's just the Good Vibes there
yeah I feel it you just see other
Muslims there and you're like you know
the [ __ ] voice
what what love it's called the black
stone and the Muslims believe according
to tradition that the stone is from Adam
Adam and Eve whoa
yeah I've never heard of that damn
Wikipedia baby Islamic tradition holds
that it fell from heaven as a guide for
Adam and Eve to build an altar has often
been described as a meteorite wow here
is a you can't see it fully but whoa
there's like a hole in the side where
you can look in and see it
oh that's on the side of the building
you can peek in and see it apparently oh
that's cool when I think of it I think
of uh when I read Malcolm X's book and
he talks about going to Kaaba and like
it really changes perspective on things
but because before uh he made that
pilgrimage he was more like
not wanting to work with other cultures
just stick to himself you know that
black should be helping black people and
white people should stay out of it but
he said when he went there and he was
you know treated like an equal amongst
all Races and colors it really changes
those perspective on things
that's beautiful yeah
well by the way these [ __ ] are
so organized look at that [ __ ] dude
that is like good
formation
are you gonna get the family chat going
think it's important
anyway listen
yeah shout out Mecca is all is my point
so what the hell were we talking about
the Saudi Prince donated 50.
but then I wanted to learn something yep
it's beautiful
you know
love that
all right where the [ __ ] were we the
Jews yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah chill
Jordan
God forbid the Jews
oh yeah I was talking about keemstar's
weird Obsession
um
and you know what he's really upset is
because he people keep trolling him with
this [ __ ]
imagine just getting like a unsolicited
DM it says do you own drum alert I used
to work for Teddy Fresh Market and I
have tea he actually responds what's up
we do a little trolling it's called I
have screenshots I can send you on here
if that works boom own [ __ ]
that's what you get for opening
unsolicited [ __ ] messages we like to
troll thork
real quick chat said I hope Travis Scott
never goes to Cabo
oh that's funny Scott never goes to Cabo
because no takaba because to Mecca yeah
why because he caused a stampede that oh
is there is that a risk there yeah well
I mean there's a bajillion people go
there yeah so wait has there ever been
like a mass casualty I don't know about
masks but I've have heard of casualties
there oh no
actually
they got to be careful how much people
they let in there
but Becca's probably like it's probably
like
and 20 hopping all year round because
Muslims go there in 2015
there was a stampede that killed over 2
000 people what
2 000 people yeah the 2015 Mina Stampede
oh my God that's tragic
uh I don't think it was actually at the
Kaaba though as part of because the the
pilgrimage has a bunch of different
stations basically that's what I was
talking about earlier there's a one part
where like you throw these rocks and
it's kind of like a metaphor of stoning
the devil or whatever and it it I think
it was at a different station
I want to see the rock throwing station
because I only ever see the
right that's like the most famous part I
want the the Kaaba part but um
let's see
wow that's horrible
Geez Louise
yeah there's been multiple mess casualty
events there apparently this is where
they throw the Rocks yeah oh my God
there's so many people there
you can see these pillars and then it
kind of so where do you get the rocks
from I think they I think they give them
out you well because it's you know it's
all a ceremony so it's it's kind of like
part of the uh
it looks like they collect them at the
bottom and recycle them yeah probably yo
it probably sounds crazy there with like
thousands of people throwing rocks right
yeah Stone the devil yeah that's what
it's
okay my uh
my uh what do you call it my Sunday
school [ __ ] from 20 years ago was
finally paying off
yeah God bless I'm learning a lot I
didn't know any of this stuff you went
to Hebrew school Dan no Dan went to this
really cool program it sounded like
what is it well I think it's a great
concept yeah the the church that I uh
grew up going to our our Sunday school
so to speak was almost just kind of like
a theology class because they just
taught us about
all religions at one point or another so
we did like whole sections on Islam and
Hinduism Buddhism and everything else
I had a class like that in high school
but I don't I just don't really remember
anything I've learned in my life
Norm normally do you guys just learn
about Christianity in school well this
wasn't at school this was at my church
actually no in high school where we
learned about all the major religions of
the world
about we learned about like Hindu
Buddhism Christian Judaism and uh Islam
yeah got it unfortunately backfired
because of Technology as well just added
to the curriculum sponsored of course by
the uh generous Church of Scientology
yeah who we love
after seeing Top Gun man you know by the
way shout out to Insider which is
basically just a tea Channel at this
point
look at this headline Ethan climb blamed
Trisha Paytas fans
for accusations that Teddy fresh is a
toxic work environment like [ __ ] shut
the [ __ ] up well
headline isn't inaccurate
but it did it's like it's written in the
most like yeah Sensational click-baity
[ __ ] internet drama [ __ ] it's a
tea Channel I mean listen yeah I mean
it's a if it was reach Lux then I would
say that's fine but it's Insider it's
embarrassing
well at this point let's stop holding
them to that standard right I mean
they're basically a tabloid
this was my favorite part they go
founder and YouTuber Ethan Klein and EO
Klein denied the claims claiming it's a
utopian workplace all right that's maybe
twisting it I was pretty sure I was
joking about that yeah
that was a joke because we said there's
a [ __ ] foosball table there
right
it makes me sound like an [ __ ] when
you read it like that right
I think a Utopia doesn't have work I
think utopian and work environment are
um that's not true sorry
we live in a society yeah so true
um anyway it's kind of funny just to see
these idiots
oh then look at the but they close out
with this Ethan Klein has been involved
in multiple disputes in his decade
online feuding with influencers
including PewDiePie James Charles what
did you Feud with Pewdiepie never yeah I
guess I don't know when he said the
n-word didn't turn into the whole thing
that wasn't in any way we were always
dogs
I'm pretty sure when we responded to go
canaro he was in it wasn't he yeah he
called in yeah dude PewDiePie Felix has
always been
incredibly uh generous and gracious and
humble and uh and great with me
personally and I I think he's a great
guy you know honestly if you look
at all the influencers in the whole
world he's one of if not the most
successful and probably the most
grounded of them all too I mean he's in
a stable relationship he keeps a pretty
private life and he seems to
I don't know he just really lives like a
really humble life with his with his
wife now wife and he really just seems
to be a pretty solid dude honestly
and I remember you guys defending
PewDiePie from tabloids doing this to
him
um yeah they were doing it to him all
the time yeah yeah yeah
anyways
yeah he is he's the [ __ ] King of
Sweden man wait
hold on
he's he's an expat though right yeah he
bailed but he but he abandoned you guys
he always has Swedish Swedish back he
never says anything bad about it he's
amazing
he dipped dude I don't know no
I love that mom
um also he's the ultimate weeaboo man he
moved to Japan I mean who Among Us can
say that
yeah yeah and you [ __ ] hit it bro
plus he wears a dope ass watch
most importantly he has a nice watch
which watch does he wear uh similar
rolly to mine
wow you're in good company loaded man go
ahead it's a father to me he says like a
father to me
you know I wonder what he thinks about
Kebab Pizza I'd like to get his oh take
on that interesting he's from Gothenburg
so definitely [ __ ] with it is that your
town
[Music]
gotcha you know you know PewDiePie gets
a lot of [ __ ] on the internet
and so do I but
I do think from everything I've seen and
all the time he's been on the internet
that he really is a
uh very solid
deep down he's a very he's a great guy a
true guy
and uh
I don't think he has a mean bone in his
body
and uh
he's like a father to love
yes more importantly
what would your dad think about that
um
I don't I think it's fine with it
honestly you have Two Dads very
Progressive yeah very Progressive just
like the bordering
exactly
just like it
I'm right
um also just I thought the coordinary
had three dads actually what does he
have three dads well because he was
keeping up the lie about having to gay
black dads for a while and then he like
slipped up and referred to his other dad
and then he tried to like right they're
in a threat scramble and come up with
some weird explanation for why that
still made sense they're in a lover
they're in a love throttle
uh speaking of keemstar and you know
people say you're the only person
keeping them relevant and it's like
to me so true it's it's it's
well listen listen no none of our fans
are going and watching his videos no
definitely not you know what I mean yeah
I think it's worth it for the memes it's
so worth it he thinks I hate him and it
honestly like I can't speak for everyone
here but I can't tell you how many days
where I'm like oh I wish we just had
something some some stupid goof to react
to and then just I'll describe he's a
law
coward yeah we've harmed him for a lot
of funny ass contests so so thank you
Kim no
anyway it's just funny keemstar went on
a podcast and uh he's complaining about
with us making fun of him eating beef
jerky and syrup with the fork when
fousey came and visited which by the way
when we found this I went to go pull the
clip
and uh fousey deleted that video oh
fousey did a whole puff piece on
keemstar it was the keemstar movie it
was called I wonder why he erased it or
they had a straight up a race it's gone
maybe because we goofed on it I think we
might have filled the comment section
with
I mean
really I mean maybe I don't know I don't
know why he would have deleted it well
it was extremely embarrassing also it
may have had something to do with it we
pointed out the fake comments too maybe
that was oh [ __ ] how he's liking every
comment right that was pretty funny like
thousands and thousands of them anyway
here here he is it's just it's just good
memes guys that's it that's all it is
this one time
um you know I had fousey over at my
house and we we edited in the original
clip for effect right fousey made like
the the keemstar movie or whatever we
went ATV and it was fun or whatever and
so I was showing fousey food that you
can only get here so I like had like
beef jerk like beef jerky and maple
syrup
only here have you ever left your city
keemstar you know there's a whole big
wide world outside Buffalo New York
foreign
basically like Slim Jims but from the
Butcher and they're like high quality
stuff and like real maple syrup that
fousey's like never tried before right
and so by the way fousey did not like
this [ __ ] for the record I hated it dude
Ethan Klein went on this tirade that I'm
in my kitchen just eating syrup and
[ __ ] meat sticks and he's made this
same joke like 10 000 [ __ ] times like
I don't
like there was a
showing fousey this stuff it's because
it's food that's just like you'd be
picking your life and not he's not even
like funny right like in such a weird
way and my response to that would be
like okay well let's pull up the video
when you and Trisha went to Disneyland
you guys ate like 15 different it's not
it's not that you're eating don't you
understand that it's what and how you're
doing it you gave this man a fork
to try the syrup with here it is [ __ ]
time this man is scooping syrup with a
fork in your opinion bro that's funny
okay listen y'all they're all sitting in
this dude's closet talking about how
funny how unfunny I am to like 8 000
viewers
and uh this man's eating syrup with a
fork now the minute
I can't admit that that's funny is when
you know they're blowing smoke up your
ass you lost the game yeah you're
surrounded by yes men oh my God it's so
good
it's not even funny dude it's not even
funny
I love that he's queued into every time
I make the joke though he's making that
joke ten thousand times stop laughing
it's not funny
the [ __ ] Disneyland video like you
eat donuts all day like what oh my God
oh my God making any sense I'm not
saying anything about anyone's weight or
eating lots of food [ __ ] dude
even in this clip it's funny you said
you can't get beef jerky maple syrup
anywhere else yep it's also like we eat
beef jerky in this office it's not bad
bro I love beef jerky it's just funny I
love beef jerky and I love maple syrup
for real and I love giving it to
visitors you know what I'm tired of this
[ __ ] I think we need to get maple syrup
and beef jerky and put it on a plate and
do a whole keemstar ceremony let's put
it to the real test let's do it on um on
Wednesday can we set that up okay
we need the keemstar ceremony of maple
syrup
beef jerky and forks
have you ever seen someone eat syrup
with a fork bruh and he served it to him
he planned this out and he planned for
him to eat it with a fork I said [ __ ]
times like I don't get it funny bro I
don't get it's not funny like there was
a reason why I was showing fousey this
stuff it's because it's food picking
your life and not he's not even like
funny right and who are you kid please I
am funny right
the bird's gotta eat no it's not funny
hey the birds also Gotta Eat Amy I got
it I guess you never go to the park and
toss bread to the moon no no no that's
too easy
it's nice
it's doing a nice thing and my response
to that would be like okay well let's
pull up the video when you and Trisha
wait where's the voice you guys ate like
15 different [ __ ] [ __ ]
in times and the span of like
what is what like
what is the OWN there he's to pull up a
video of you guys going to a theme park
and eating lots of treats near the theme
park yeah it may again he's incoherent
as usual like it reminds me of when he
was doing that Papa gut debate and he
was like you criticized me of having a
20 year old girlfriend yet you defended
your wife when someone called her ugly
Checkmate atheist it's like what what
huh makes no sense but there we have it
we love it and I'm excited to be eating
syrup with a fork in fact let's do a
poll right now we have 44 000 people
watching let's do a poll is it funny
just is it funny yes or no because there
seems to be a consensus over there that
it's not funny right it's not funny it's
funny well hold on Lilo let's do a poll
is someone inviting someone over your
house
saying that you can't get beef jerky and
um and syrup anywhere else
and then preparing a meal where they
have to Fork syrup out of a plate
now early vote is looking pretty good 88
percent
are saying yes it is funny
it's funny so we but yeah 88 say yes so
I guess
I guess funny I guess there are some
among them that think you know it's just
not fun
so there you have it
88 yes surprised it was a 12 no some
people are saying I accidentally voted
no so some people saying I voted no
because it's not funny it's hilarious so
there's that okay that is what they were
saying right yeah
nice all right hzy but we love him for
that don't we love the king cooteri oh
[ __ ] you guys there's we haven't talked
about trailer or Cav Cab in so long and
trailer's getting sued they have a new
lawsuit for stiff they stray up [ __ ]
stiffed
people they owed money creators
content creators are suing triller
claiming am I angry let me finish they
weren't paid for their work because they
weren't black wait what yeah this story
is very odd yeah but just you'll you'll
see oh it did it fake two-way
influencers Sue Tick Tock rival trailer
claiming it reneged on deal to pay them
for their work and they have fired them
after a company raised 14 million fund
to compensate black content creators
only
well did they owe you money or not uh
two creators joined trailer in July and
August 2020 when the app was all set on
the rise and worked closely with the
company's content moderator manager uh
Kendra Johnson in October they pitched
the idea of a virtual crater house
called troop house
and Johnson asked them to be the captain
of it
Johnson made an oral assurance that they
would be paid for their efforts and
growing The Troop House channel as
captains once trailer could afford to do
so I love that listen we just can't
afford it right now
we just can't afford it and November
trailer announced 14 million dollar fund
to pay black creators on its platform
so Ferrero and Papa
asked John sin about when they get their
paychecks since trailer seemed to now
have the fun to pay their creators
dude you [ __ ] spent like a you wasted
a billion dollars last year kavkav I
love that he doesn't have money to pay
them they claimed that she became angry
laughed at their request and told them
to wait their turn and hung up on the
phone
they arranged a meeting with trailer
chairman Bobby
who promised they would get money in
March 2022 here is said guy with our boy
kavkav
and it says Tick Tock is for kids
um
that's weird
and and what is true
creeps
hello are you really you're trying to
steal Their audience why would you right
you brought over like Noah back and
Dicky demilio yeah well who are you
trying to attract if it's not for kids
it's kind of crazy appropriate
relationship with a four-year-old
Natalie Portman oh no oh oh that's who
he's talking about oh no
first hand experience
weirdo
I missed calf calf it's been too long
since we're talking about this guy it
has been
uh maybe you should check back in with
him love just be like do you still want
to talk or no
yeah I'll I'll do that definitely
um
let's see
he reached out to Bobby but in February
they were kicked from triller's
messaging channels unfollowed on social
media and told triller no longer wishes
to partner with you and rejects your
request for paid agreements for future
content and red uh read retribution for
past content screenshot of the emails
let's go haters
yeah I mean that's kind of Ryan's Mo I
just want to keep trying to tell people
to keep going into business with him I
says this guy is gonna he's he's not
trustworthy yeah he's not he you know
what I mean
so here's the email they got from
the trailer
People based off of your recent
unacceptable actions and Communications
triller no longer wishes to partner with
you Thriller rejects your request for
paid agreements for future content and
retribution for pascon
they reject
the request for payment
I'm gonna try that with mine yeah
utility bills DWP yeah
I reject all bills I get rung up at the
grocery store no I'm not paying for that
it's like uh with peace and love no more
bills thank you thank you and Michael
Scott declared bankruptcy right yeah
yeah declare bankruptcy
well Ryan knows all too well what
actually bankruptcy entails for God's
sakes he's been through it how many
times
you know triller Rejects
all requests for paid agreements
[ __ ] paid agreement you said it
right there
for past content
we as a company are currently working to
uplift support and contribute to Black
creators and take pride as thought
leaders in this area
I feel like they're using this black
Creator thing to just [ __ ] people over
like what it seems definitely weird like
that angle of the story was bizarre to
me because it seemed very unnecessary to
even
bring that into the law it's almost like
they did it so that they could
specifically scam not pay them which is
so [ __ ] weird like there's nothing
wrong with wanting to lift up black
creators but the way that they're like
parading it around like well we only
care about black creators right now and
therefore we're not going to pay you
now that's a little [ __ ] wonky Cav
Kev
for you both to see trailer's gift of
paid agreements to Black creators as an
opportunity for your own monetary gain
is incredibly disappointing and not a
conversation we are open to having it
sounds like you guys owe them money
it also demonstrates that you do not
understand the support the triller brand
or platform
you also attempted to record a meeting
without a written consent and have sent
language to our chairman that you are
victims in all of this
sounds like it even in the way you wrote
this
as such trailer hereby terminates all
affiliation with you both and triller
well the lesson is don't get oral
agreements from Trailer because they'll
[ __ ] you everywhere every time we are
looping on our legal counsel Darren
Traub in case you have any questions
also adding in Bobby on bbcc for
visibility
wow and then they sign it best yeah love
that best wishes Tata peace
that's interesting I'm interested to see
how this followed this up
yeah
it sounds like you guys owe these girls
some money hey
hmm
do we know who these girls are Carolyn
and Milana
no I don't think that this troop house
this thing had even gotten off the
ground from the way the article was
written it was like something that they
were trying to launch and but they must
be on their wheels uh social media
figures well they were just managing the
house I think I don't think that they
were
type type Carolyn and Milana troop house
let's see if something comes up
[Music]
yo he's such a scumbag dude [ __ ] over
like kids
while saying Tick Tock is for kids
what a weirdo
they are content creators but I've never
heard of them before true Palace
introducing troop house still up on
trailer oh yeah let me read articles
because like
oh this is her
Troopers hi my name is Janet hey guys my
name is Mary my name is Cambria hey
everyone I'm Mia hi my name is Jocelyn
Martinez these are straight up kids and
they're like hey [ __ ] you kid you piece
of [ __ ] you're racist we owe you nothing
good day
holy [ __ ] hi I'm Nessa K hi my name is
Danielle hi I'm Elena Blair hi I'm
Noelle bellinghausen hi guys my name is
Carolyn Marie I am the van hey my name
is
there hi everyone my name is Caroline
hey guys it's boarding school for women
there's like 20 people in that house
holy [ __ ]
well
rip to the troop house rip troop house
man bomb but not forgotten yeah
thank you
stupid ass Ryan Kavanaugh what an idiot
what a loser content here
yo went trailer goes bankrupt eventually
we gotta have a party
oh that's not tap dance on their grave
that's not right thank you psych cap
dance I'll be [ __ ] Dave and Buster's
baby yeah I'll be David
oh I'll be Dave and busting all over
their grave
hey hey
okay cab wet them wet and Reckless I
you're actually feckless oh I'm a little
worried about freestyling yeah yeah me
too yeah
nice try Zach
wet and Reckless
[ __ ] you're penniless
getting cooked by Brad the bowl
scamming little kids so you don't have
to pay making fun of tick tock is for
kids but hey that's who you want get my
trailer
cooked by Bread the bowl Brad the bull
riding it like at
hey on Sunset Boulevard all I'll say is
Variety article
Variety article about what Variety
article what's the name of the variety
articles
[Music]
Variety article about what Variety
article about what
getting cooked like right in the bowl at
Saddle Peak Ranch
fossil fighting memos about sexual
harassment to not pay your president
Brian Kavanaugh Brian Kavanaugh Brian
what Ryan what hit and run wet and
Reckless oh you're feckless Fred the
bull [ __ ] your wife till you're
headless dad my necklace forging some
art
Brad [ __ ] your wife because you're
[ __ ] you're freckless your penniless
own next own next oh next oh next
yo you got the troop house more like the
flipped house the thing is flipped
[Music]
one star it's one star or more one star
one star or more leave a review of
triller if you liked it or not one star
or more it's up to you visit count does
Ryan Kavanaugh look like Harvey
weinstein.com too you know I got some
bad news oh [ __ ] we need to do some work
what the hell we have dropped
significantly oh well hold on uh right
flipped I think it was that rep wait
click wait Google right Google Ryan
Kavanaugh I just did oh yeah they click
on the website
yeah I'm just saying we're like fifth or
sixth result now I just yeah I think
what we need to do is for is I think
people need to
Google Ryan Kavanaugh and then click the
website because I don't want you to
misspell it in the URL
and you should do a little brush up on
your lore
let's Google Google and then go to
Google yeah
not there he is yeah
okay and then scroll down down not this
not that not there not that no not that
here it is there you go yeah that one
that's the one oh I'd like to see our
videos are there in the search result
that's new go back
Ryan Cavanaugh just filed his third
lawsuit against me Ryan Cavanaugh CEO of
trailers a horrible person love that
it's wonderful you know he's not loving
that
and can you check can you check his
Wikipedia page I don't I wonder if they
were have won any battles there because
I haven't been following
I mean yeah controversies legal issues
it's still pretty
they got some new [ __ ] in there about uh
Natalie Portman I don't think that was
in there before in 2004 an email came
through Sony picture hack was publishing
which Kavanaugh decries the US
government's handling of Gaza Israel
conflict among the recipients was
Natalie Portman who described the thread
as very disturbing and complained to
Kavanaugh that she did not consent to
have her private email address included
in the mailing list and wish to be
removed Kevin responded sorry you are
right shoes
sorry you are right Jews being
slaughtered is much less important than
your email address being shared with 20
of our peers and continue to include our
email list that's [ __ ] a great update
I'm the first Jew on stage in Texas
dude that's a really good update
is throw still crushing it in the mod
log
I have not been here in a minute it's
protected
wait what like this article is oh locked
dude it's locked down hard because
listen you got to make sure that
everything is legit here throws my bully
dude and pop Pokey 35 too [ __ ]
Legendary Heroes of of frankly
these guys are basically librarians
scribes of the library of Alexander
Alexandria or whatever the [ __ ] yeah
these these guys are Scholars they are
great men and and and and I commend that
they're women or non yeah people yeah
sorry to assume agenda there they're
great individuals who are committed to
uh the dissemination of Truth yeah
silent Guardians silent Guardians
anything else popping up uh this dude
that's I love that they added that
Natalie Portman one uh
go up a bit under
are you trying to find a source yeah
this is a really well sourced article by
the way
well I'm looking specifically Because
the actual uh Email exchange with
Natalie Portman is really [ __ ] funny
because it's like riddled with typos
remember he misspelled Holocaust well he
was drunk probably yeah yeah Holocaust
I love that he's so obsessed with like
Jew victim [ __ ] and you can't even spell
holocaust
uh in 2006 Kevin I was arrested after
being accused of driving under the
influence of alcohol DUI and being
involved in a hit and run all but the do
I charge which was lessened to wet and
Reckless was dropped Kevin I was placed
on three years of probation in order to
pay a fine and take counseling and
alcohol education programs while on
probation for as early do I arrest
Kavanaugh was arrested for speeding and
drunk driving with a suspended license
dude that's bad okay I'm not pled guilty
to violating his probation and the other
charges would drop Kavanaugh then began
using a driver
uh did you know about the one under it
that was a new addition too yeah that
one's so funny dude he got criminally
investigated for impeding
a Manhunt because he landed his
helicopter on a sheriff's helipad during
a man hunt dude
isn't that crazy
yeah uh the investigation was later
closed after it was concluded that
Kavanaugh had received prior permission
okay I'm just throwing that out there so
you know right that's good to cover the
bases yeah
um
are you going for this to the source
yeah oh yeah if you pulled up the
newspaper from free halocast you can see
it there on the it's highlighted yellow
too Holocaust all right so we spelled it
that twice [ __ ] yeah no that's not
that's how he thinks it's spelled
no no listen I'm a terrible speller you
guys have all seen evidence of that I
noticed about Holocaust
and I don't even like or you also just
like know how to use spell check
yeah I mean how do you not you like you
see the red line under it right you
don't you don't want to fact check
Holocaust but I do know how to spell
holocaust I really do well that's good
yeah h-o-l-o-c-a-u-s-t
are you looking at me for verification
like I spelled it wrong no I didn't look
at you like anything you just
Holocaust
h-o-l-o-c-a-u-s-t Holocaust
[Applause]
I'll let you cost
Holocaust Hala
I'll let your boy go back to Wikipedia
and see if there's anything else juicy
updates there for Ryan cavkev
legal issues go up Sony picture hacks
Kevin I frequently used a personal
helicopter for daily commuting
the resulting disturbance prompted some
of his neighbors to submit claim
complaints to the state and local
officials
when it was revealed that the hotel
cabinet used for landing was legally
permitted only for emergency Landings a
spokesperson for Kavanaugh expressed his
intention to stop Landing there I mean
what an entitled jerk dude what what
bro oh whoa 2012 Kevin I was targeted by
an extensive extortion plot that was
mainly aimed at Harvey Weinstein
perpetrator sent a letter to Kavanaugh
demanding 11 million threatening the
lives of his family members oh that's
horrible A day after receiving the
letter
Vivek Shah who had been photographed
with Kavanaugh event 2011 was arrested
on extortion charges and eventually
convicted to seven years of prison
that's interesting
weird connection to Harvey there yes the
connections keep coming up Ryan
Cavanaugh is a force of nature it
doesn't mention it here um but in
relation to the Sony emails I think
it wasn't just that 20 other people had
Natalie Portman's emails it was when
Sony got hacked her email got leaked to
the public as well because of this
interaction that she didn't want to have
in the first place right yeah she had
probably long since abandoned the email
though yeah yeah and it already outed
him but she's like dude I understand it
why are you adding me on a thread with
20 people I don't know yeah it's like
what the [ __ ] bro about like some really
incendiary like controversial topic too
right and also by the way Natalie
Portman I know she's Israeli but she
I've she's like very critical of Israel
if you know anything about her that's
not
hurt the vibe she's into I wonder if
this was before or after he joked about
having sex with young Natalie Portman an
inappropriate relationship with a 40
year old man 14 year old Natalie
apartment well we could find out
when did that happen godhead love to
pick her brain on Ryan Cavanaugh I don't
care she probably got stories to tell
boys and Kavanaugh uh Natalie Port well
it's probably just [ __ ] about this email
controversy is going to come up well
anyway just a little Cav cab update for
you guys
bro speaking of which
or I don't know how do I connect these
topics speaking of Harvey Weinstein
he said that in 2014
and when did this
email conversation happens it's down if
you go down
on the Wiki page scroll down
uh
just 14. oh it was the same year or
right around the same time oh my God I
talked to my girl Natalie reach out and
say hey we're reaching out for a
question about I mean you'll respond to
that let's reach out thank you okay she
knows
she doesn't want to get sued man
Natalie's Rich she ain't afraid of him
she's in power not everybody is down to
get [ __ ] Natalie Portman is an
empowered woman dude I'll hit her up
about the Holocaust wall that'll break
the ice
oh yeah right right to them though for
real just say hey we wanted to get some
comment about Ryan Kavanaugh
yeah Rick you guys remember Ricky Martin
the
um Livin La Vida Loca oh he's living the
Crazy Life all right so first it came
out that he was gay like I don't know
how long ago that was but that was years
and years ago everyone like suspected he
was gay but I guess everyone's like okay
he is gay
did he just have one hit or was there
more
you're muted
sorry I was muted but he's had lots of
hits overseas especially
okay
so he yeah this story's [ __ ] insane
you guys
um
wait
Ricky Martin net worth I'm just trying
to get an idea
and it's not showing how tall is he
that's a good question actually
Ricky Martin height
I bet you he's a tall King
six foot I knew it I'm seeing 130
million
really yeah he's super yeah he's like a
he's like a Latin America pup he yeah he
had like duets with like Britney Spears
and uh
he was on Glee okay okay so super super
successful pop musician Ricky Martin has
been accused of essay in Puerto Rico but
get this a new report from a Spanish
News website identifies Ricky's accuser
as his 21 year old nephew
here he would introduce incest we're the
singer's brother reportedly identified
the alleged victim on a Puerto Rican law
there are harshal penalties for certain
essay
when the alleged victim is related to
the Accuser
uh Ricky's nephew alleged ended a
seven-month relationship with Ricky and
did not take it well continuing to
contact his nephew and showing up at his
nephew's home Ricky could face 50 years
if convicted
Ricky Martin's attorney denies the claim
say unfortunately the person who made
this claim is struggling with deep
mental health issues Ricky of course
would never
have romantic relations with his nephew
the idea is not only untrue it's
disgusting we hope this man gets urgent
help but most of all we look forward to
this awful case being dismissed
um
[ __ ] dude 50 years for screwing his
nephew
inside out
50
I mean look it's hard to know I don't
know if what's true or not but if that's
true that's [ __ ] Wild
Duty [ __ ] his nephew let's go yeah
that's the Alabama moment boys
I didn't [ __ ] my niece boy
um
damn
so there you have it
oh my God and speaking of weird essay of
old old people essaying young people
I saw this Tick Tock and it was it's
just okay it's so bizarre this story
blew my mind man
there's a Harris 45 year old Harris
named Savannah daisley she's currently
um oh she's currently in jail in
Australia
until an August court date
um now she's being accused of
essentially R wording a 14 year old boy
and she has
found a way to uh
turn this into a marketing opportunity
for herself she's writing articles about
her her affair
like in a fluffy kind of way and then
putting in call out store products is
crazy this guy figured it out this video
doesn't have that many views but I
absolutely
dropped my jaw when I watched it use
this kind of tactic but watch this video
shout out to this guy pissed
Magistas till the end because this is
one of the maddest things I have seen in
a while and I am not referring to the
fact that this is a older woman who has
sexually assaulted a teenage boy I think
that's a lot more common than probably
most people realize and I'm also not
referring to the bizarrely complementary
tone all the journalists who have
written about this story seem to be
using to describe this particular child
molester calling her things like the
Glamorous heiress the Glamorous mother
of two this one just refers to her as
the brunette that seems a bit casual to
me I'm also not referring to the many
depressing yet highly predictable
comments mostly from older men about oh
this is every young boy's dream and
where were women like this when I was a
young boy this is not a crime this is a
gift I think we all saw that [ __ ]
coming what I am referring to is that
every single article I can find on this
contains passages like this her business
was launched on the back of a popular
14-day detoxification and weight
management program lower down it says
Savannah has helped thousands of people
detoxify their body lose weight yada
yada they're here reverse the aging
process look here's the exact same
passage in a different article and even
says that it's from her own company's
website this is an ad campaign 100 this
is right is an ad campaign look here
it's promoting her new book the brunette
is the author of two books 14 day smart
cleanse and the forthcoming epigenetics
look this one from the Sun even includes
a testimonial from a satisfied customer
and the price of her products This Woman
This glamorous child molesting brunette
is paying journalists to help her spin
the free publicity she's getting from
molesting a minor into what has to be
the most bizarre ad campaign of all time
pretty incredible I never I've never
seen or heard anything like this
but um
how [ __ ] crazy is that
um here's some of the great comments he
was talking about I feel bad for the kid
I could only imagine how sore his arm is
from all the high fives dude you're so
embarrassing
dude that's so [ __ ] crazy
I just don't understand why it's like
if the I know it's like a cliche but
if the roles were reversed it would be
so outrageous everyone understands for
some reason how [ __ ] up that is right
but when a 45 year old woman
is having sex with a 14 year old
it's like something to even joke about
it's not even this is the plot to every
80s teen movie no he's 14 he's in Middle
School
how old is 14. yeah eighth grade or nine
eighth or ninth grade oh they're Middle
School dude
that is the plot to every 80s Teen Movie
what high school kid doesn't wish that I
mean it's Middle School
damn that 14 year old is the man and
he's about to get paid nice
that boy's a legend oh and of course
what 80s movie this uh very
well-adjusted person beautiful black
king
left that comment
what I would give to be 14 again a
teenager's dream come true wish I met
her when I was 14. That's crazy dude
that people still write that [ __ ] and I
didn't those comments were at the top
just the video didn't have a lot of
views yeah right these were all the
comments yeah
I just I was like because there's like
this is the plot to every 80s teen movie
and I'm like
racking my like what 80s team movie
had as a plot point that like a young
man sleeping with like a teacher
so I just Googled 80s team movie about
hot teacher
and then our results is Stand and
Deliver
hey what is standing delivery it's a
movie with Edward James Olmos about
teaching the inner city kids how to do
calculus oh oh but there's no sex
there's definitely no sex absolutely not
it's actually it's a great piece
actually I remember I think I've seen
that movie it's really good I love this
movie Edward James almost is the man I
love this actor uh but yeah I wouldn't
necessarily
14 the kid is 14. that's crazy you know
the thing is like it seems to be like oh
that's awesome dude it's gonna [ __ ] that
kid up no question dude trust me it's
[ __ ] up
you know what movie I was gonna suggest
we watch on a future member stream is
That's my boy I was just gonna say
because that movie is insane it is it's
like the same it's it's not plotted yeah
it's not plot exactly like the young boy
hooks up with his teacher gets her
pregnant and like everyone's turn them
on the whole school's cheering for him
he becomes a celebrity because of it
yeah yeah wait wait for real yeah yeah
and like he becomes a celeb and he's
like oh and his life is awesome yeah and
she's like and like
it's so insane like we watch it's an
Adam Sandler movie it's not that old
what the [ __ ]
that's my boy they kind of buried it
because it it did so awful That's my boy
it's like to be like at a boy whoa what
the [ __ ] dude no [ __ ] and straight up to
be honest it's probably one of my
favorite movies oh Zach
why why it's just funny dude
I I
um picture is supposed to be a [ __ ]
teenager both this guy looks like he's
almost 30. well here's the plot Adam
Sandler grows up and he needs 50 Grand
for like tax evasion or some [ __ ] so he
goes to find his son Andy Samberg
and coincidentally he's getting married
so it's about them kind of reconnecting
and it's
and so is it touching is that heart but
he does look like a fully grown ass man
just saying well they're saying that
happens there's a Time skill yeah film
he's Adam Sandler's washed up now and
broke
yeah but when he's like a kid he starts
sleeping with the teacher and the
teacher starts like looking at him in
class and starts like doing movements
like that and everyone in school is like
oh you're the man and then they get
caught on stage having sex the child
with the teacher and the whole school
starts cheering him on whoa and she gets
the and becomes a rock star the the Adam
Sandler gets the teacher pregnant yeah
so whoa yeah oh and this is his son
and this isn't the product of that
correct Andy Steinberg
what a [ __ ] somebody pointed out big
big does have
the wait so I first of all I like big
but let me let me reassess he I know he
he's an adult
no no he's a kid that becomes an adult
yes and they sleep together yes do they
have sex or did they just like sleep
together I think it's implied that they
do
I don't believe they do I think they
they kissed or something I think they
just spent the night oh no no no no no
no no they they do they do have sex for
sure that happens in them because he
gets all like excited and starts running
down the street and [ __ ] on the
trampoline Okay in her defense he has
the body of a grown man right but I
think she knows that at that point that
he's a kid no there's no way yeah yeah
but he has the body of a grown man yeah
tomahan yeah right it's just it's Tom
Hanks yeah like in the he goes the
zoltar mission I used to love that movie
as a kid bro yeah me too
that's who he convinced his friend it
was him
he sings him Nelly
I don't know what even what it was I
just know that that's right I was
kidding
that is in that really song
did he sleep with the lady in big that's
what I wrote
in the movie Big did Josh and Susan have
sex
there you go
uh my daughter and I were watching Big
she asked me this question I couldn't
really answer it it looks implied
but would they have done that even in
the 80s I love this movie and the answer
wouldn't matter I'm just curious almost
certainly yes with the lights on yeah
absolutely on the trampoline
in the novelization of the book that I
read as a kid they most definitely had
sex
I remember a mobilization of big yeah
listen to this I distinctly remember a
scene about Josh his internal monologue
about touching her breasts for the first
time
wait big was a novel or did they no no
for some [ __ ] god unknown reason
they turned the movie into a book it has
four ratings by the way let's read those
I'd like to read it yeah what let's see
of three stars always loved the movie
and bought this on Amazon why not just
watch the movie
time paperback always loved moving this
on Amazon watch the movie again just
recently finally got around to reading
the company book not bad
three stars okay okay fair enough
a lot of people also pointing out the
film blank check uh involves a young
child uh is that right [ __ ] I don't know
oh blank check whoa
[ __ ] I just remember that movie some
some dude runs over his bike yes and
then he's like here just take a check
and then somehow this kid caches it for
millions of dollars no problem
wait that guy that kid got laid
I don't know if they slept together but
they
they kiss at least wait let's start
blank check inappropriate
inappropriate sex
or an appropriate relationship with a
fortune yeah you know exactly what I'm
talking about here Kafka
okay wait Disney plus this is from last
year Disney plus users are left outrage
over deeply disturbing here let me show
you deeply disturbing scene in the 1994
comedy blank check that shows an adult
Woman kissing an 11 year old boy on the
mouth yo that's crazy I watched that
movie twice I didn't even think about
that [ __ ] Tick-Tock user Rob Aniston
shared video of himself watching blank
check on was they saying the movie has
the most awkward scene ever in the film
fifth grader Preston Waters gets a kiss
from Shea a 30-something FBI agent
posting as a bank teller wait you we
gotta find this being a creep it's the
most realistic scene in the film oh this
is it wait I gotta see it so when can I
see what they say
[Music]
why don't you give me a call and say
about 10 years
that's wild okay
wait he's supposed to be how old is this
11. six years would just be 17. so they
agreed on six years then it'd be
probably close to 40.
what the [ __ ] no oh I gotta watch that
again
she wants to [ __ ] this kid already
you guys think it's a joke
yo that's crazy
what's crazy is that actress actually
had to kiss this kid
yeah
whoa
that's awesome
yeah that's got to be the worst thing
that's been left in a modern movie
wow I wonder if they pulled it
they gotta edit that out that's insane
but I just love how the characters like
I want to [ __ ] you now but I have to
wait just six years
oh he negotiates her down yeah yeah she
says 10 and he gets her down to six but
she still wants to she kisses him she's
still into him
someone's saying Pretty Little Liars
yeah oh for real I wrote a paper about
it last semester Pretty Paper about it I
did
um
for my my final in history and
television how do I describe it for
Google Arya and Ezra relationship they
started dating in okay so the first
episode she goes to a bar she's underage
and this guy is there and she hooks up
with him and it turns out he's her
English teacher and they date throughout
the entire series and I was a kid I was
like 12 watching it me and all my
friends we rooted for them to end up
together and they did
true love so it's college or high school
high school
um
the show's the one that I watch I was in
like no no I just spent the show there
was a college or High School
relationship just BuzzFeed article from
2020 is about how awesome it is oh wait
no I'll actually
there's one big part of the team drama
that I just can't get on board with Arya
and Ezra's relationship
so how old is this girl supposed to be
she was 10th grade I think when it
started and he's a teacher there yeah
they're one of the central couples of
the show and I remember almost everyone
rooting for them in 2010 but the thing
is Ezra is arya's teacher
yo that is such a [ __ ] up thing
horrible can you imagine that someone's
teacher they're having a secret
relationship and he's portrayed as the
good guy and all of her friends know
yo yeah times have changed man in 10
years Lucy Haley may have been 21 when
she first appeared but she was supposed
to be 16 and her teacher was supposed to
be at least 22 or 23. let's [ __ ] go
and her dad was a teacher like the
characters dad written in is a teacher
so it's just extra that
holy [ __ ] and he's a creep too who
sleeps with his students oh my God the
dad yeah he does
Pretty Little Liar not even close to the
premise the premise is like pretty
little their friend is murdered and
they're getting texts that's that these
are all side plots by the way yeah
remember when Arya from Pretty Little
Liars had an affair with her teacher and
we all just watched him rooted for them
to end up together is that why we're all
like this
whoa that yeah 2010 that's crazy how
[ __ ] changed oh
our mod Mega awesome brings up a good
point he said no Ethan the most epped up
thing in cinema is when Lou is what
Lewis did in Revenge of the Nerds and
how everyone cheered for it oh yeah
that's okay let me pull that up
um
Lewis from Revenge of the Nerds I don't
think you can even show it can't show it
I just want to describe it I don't
remember you don't remember I I remember
so here let me read it it says uh
revenge of the nerd filmmaker addresses
controversial r words scene I regret
that
oh over class uh once a classic revenge
of the nurse doesn't quite hold up
under the bright light of 2019 a fact
that not even its cast director writer
can ignore
and GQ oral history for the comedy 35th
Anniversary director Jeff
and writer Steve discussed the film's
controversial r word scene in which one
of the Nerds has
sex under false pretense with the
Sorority Girl
he so um
so towards the end of Revenge of nerds
lead nerd Lewis sees his Crush Betty
fighting with her boyfriend Stan and
decides to take advantage of the opening
Lewis
steel stands Darth Vader mask and
follows Betty into a fun house
where they proceed to have sex when
Betty asked him to take off the mask he
declines until afterward when he reveals
that he's not Stan after all
you're that nerd says Betty momentarily
surprise God you are wonderful are all
nerds as good as you she asked yes
because all jocks think about his Sports
says Louis all we ever think about is
sex at the end of the film Lewis and
Betty start dating effectively rewarding
this horrible Behavior that's
interesting
yeah
after watching that as a kid
I didn't even think about it when I was
a kid yeah I'm not talking about it
either but Darth Vader straight up well
they make it seem like he got that dub
yeah they were all cheering him on and
like they got revenge on the Revenge
which one of these guys did that this
dude I think so Carradine yeah what the
[ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
I've seen some people in chat say
Sandlot how could you compare Sandlot to
what we're talking about wait what
happened in sand line okay he's a kid
yeah he grabs one peppercorn yeah wait
what happened to Sandler he like he
pretends to drown
yeah it's like a eight-year-old I don't
know it's more like when adults are
doing crazy ass [ __ ] I was just trying
to remember what's another one um
oh God it's on the tip of my tongue I
can't remember now
oh
this is real very interesting
[Music]
um oh the obvious one is the um
the one that Ryan Cavanaugh references
oh yeah the professional Leon yeah that
shit's super weird is it not I think
it's supposed to be but it makes me
really uncomfy the first time I watched
that movie
there is
wasn't it like there originally was
is it based on a book or something I I
think so I think it's some version of it
there's like a romantic thing in it but
then they there was ancient the movie to
make it more just like a father-daughter
thing no she wanted to [ __ ] him but
maybe he just he's like he didn't he
refuses her yeah yeah
so maybe it's not as bad as I remember
but there was like a version of it where
they do hook up or something the thing
that made me comfy is how they portray
her as like this sexual being when she's
obviously like super young yeah
isn't that uh
what's his name
which he he's a bit of a weirdo I think
he did date someone very young so but it
suggested B movie
you like jazz I see a lot of people
saying uh 16 Candles
I really remember Sixteen Candles to
tell you the truth it's just kind of
like the the one of the shittier John
Hughes movies
yeah there's like an assault in the
beginning it says 16 Candle doesn't stop
at misogyny and racism it also includes
a dose of homophobia in the form of
slurs first call Sam
just calls Ted a Geisler while they're
on the bus
well that was just normal at the time
sadly
yeah the our culture of the 1980s
explained by 16 Candles the Beloved
romantic comedy
depicts a date or a word scene uh okay
yeah I don't I'm like reading the plot
summary I don't remember this movie at
all
neither
well
I do they're just in a car and he oh
it's Anthony Michael Hall sir over and
over and she's like no oh he's just
really persistent yeah it's not it's not
the love interest it's like her best
friend or something it's weird
or maybe just like a nerd should go down
in Beetlejuice
Beetlejuice
well I guess it'll use his r words let's
be real yeah he's trying to make uh
what's her name marry him
Howard the Duck
Back to the Future come on y'all are
digging now back to the Back to the
Future what scene what no back in the
future does have well what his mom wants
him oh yeah no no I'm talking about Biff
tries to race oh yeah he's not portrayed
right right but I'm just I mean yeah
saying that that is a thing that happens
in that movie I always say it's a bad
guy I mean as a kid I was always like
you know it's kind of not fair I mean
I'm happy Marty got the dub but it's
kind of not fair for um Biff to go
through that like to have his whole
future [ __ ] because but yeah then it
wasn't until I was like oh no he's a
straight up r word or like you
sympathize with Biff he's saying as a
kid he didn't understand the
implications I really want to put that
out there
you put it up do you like Griff baby you
like Griff no not a group fan not a
griffin
oh okay that about wraps it up but um
I'm excited to say on Wednesday we'll be
doing our
big beef jerky syrup Fork reveal salute
ceremony right
exciting
I'm gonna set the lamp Before Time
it
alright guys thanks for watching
everybody oh I didn't even address the
title yeah I've got terrible news um
oh [ __ ] guys I've been meaning to talk
about this terrible news
um
[Music]
um
what was it I'm a bit Defender
that you're Biff Defender that's
terrible
Dan you got anything
uh yeah the um
it was a slow news day oh yeah we didn't
have much to talk about that's the
terrible we had no good title this
episode [ __ ] sucks that's the that's
the terrible news no the terrible news
is that all of our childhood movies
involve some creepy ass [ __ ] that is
terrible terrible news that's terrible
news
uh terrible I think terrible news you're
about to terrible news you're about to
watch the worst episode of the History
Podcast yeah sorry you already fell for
it losers
terrible news guys
um
yeah somebody pointed the terrible news
guys
I lost my hair
[Music]
it's terrible it's not your fault
[Applause]
but hit him with the you need to leave
Zach no no no don't get it
because we
there's a bright spot it's not your
don't use that when I'm making a joke
save it for that
terrible news guys um
we're going to Turkey
to get a hair transplant I hate to be
the bearer of bad news bad news bad news
Did we tell you that we watched Mike's
whole video of his journey to Turkey to
go to oh God no how was it
was interesting I mean it's insanely
cheap
really it's like literally like
two grand or something where and the
work is good well I guess that remains
to be seen he just posted the video last
week so we'll see when it grows out
right Mike doesn't strike me as a poor
I'm sure he has some money by now it's
like I just don't think he needs to fly
to Turkey to get achieved well
apparently you can I mean it's not like
shady to do this turkey is is like the
most uh experienced with doing this for
whatever shady I just think it's a lot
of hubbub when you can get it done in
your own City I wonder if yeah but I
mean it's the difference between like 20
grand and and two grand even with like a
and plus you get a trip to Turkey I mean
I mean he lost his ass on all that dink
doing stuff all right yeah I wonder if
he financed it through one of his board
Apes right yeah he got a loan through
his board eh yeah yeah
anyway we have terrible news um
foreign
terrible news guys um
gotta wake up early tomorrow
damn
terrible news guys I have to eat salad
for dinner tonight
rip
[ __ ] anything else you guys want to
throw on the terrible news segment or
I got bad news yeah I'd love to hear
from you bad news good
my
my birthday's on Wednesday and I don't
want to get old oh that is bad news
that's rough buddy that is
158
58 yeah wow you know that is old
almost Ethan's age that is terrible news
shut up
shut the [ __ ] up baby
don't everybody's everybody saw that
Evie did that everyone saw never not to
leave after the show today someone says
someone said uh early brim said how come
Ethan won't run for office he's got a
constituency
constituency he's got campaign funds
what you're when you're so eager to
spend my money on this dumb thing
and he's got a good middle of the road
candidacy we need someone like him are
you trying to ruin my life
hell no
I do really think I could ever get stop
I'm not 40. nobody said you were I saw
that [ __ ]
I don't know what you're talking about
do you really think I could win anything
I've said so much dumb [ __ ] on this
podcast yeah you can you imagine the hit
ad on me it would be unbelievable
I mean think about who has been our
president and like all the [ __ ] out
about him he's still there but he
doesn't have like video of him saying
slurs and [ __ ] just audio recording
weird but just just him bragging about
saying people which is obviously in my
opinion way way worse yeah I feel like
the bar is on the floor the problem is I
think all the libs would the thing is
when you're a conservative you can
literally do anything but the libs are
gonna see that highlight clip and then
be like I [ __ ] hate that guy yeah I
don't think I could do it
yeah
what do you guys want me to run for
podcast host yeah I don't want to do it
bro I'm good podcast of the year I'm not
40. shut up
I'm 37 I just turned 37.
freshly 37. stop put it away
turn off the music
Ethan Jeff 2024
no there's a ticket yeah
one good eye and one good heart I don't
know not a heart
one good eye and one good brain I don't
know Howard's running for president
and chose uh Bradley Cooper as his VP
yeah I saw that all right listen guys
love ya
have a great week thanks for being here
I had a had a fun show today
hey okay
um
[Music]
no I can't get it I got it I gotta go
it's almost five already cut it cut the
music I got kids we could go out on this
you know yeah yeah I love that Vibe but
thanks guys I had a fun show it was a
good times and uh Wednesday we'll be
back
with another Banger get those Forks out
Orson syrup baby it's not funny Ethan
dude it's not even funny there's nothing
funny about eating syrup with a fork
it's like funny bro nobody's laughing
[Music]
idiots idiots idiots idiots it's funny
all right don't stop this beat is too
contagious
[Music]
oh all right let's take them out
foreign
[Music]